in this course you will learn everything
you need to do to start your own
software as a service company you will
learn how to build and deploy a full
stack AI SAS from the ground up you'll
even learn how to charge subscription
fees using stripe the app you will
develop uses nexjs open Ai typescript
and Tailwind Elliott Chong created this
course he specializes in creating
comprehensive tutorials to build AI
powered applications let's pop in I'm
Elliot a software developer from
Singapore and today I'm going to
Showcase uh what I've built here which
is a chat with PDF says product I'm
going to teach you how to build it from
scratch so this is a sales platform that
is a clone of original product called
tab PDF itself and how it works is
really simple you can basically drop any
PDF you want here and you're able to use
open AI to interact with a PDF so for
example for the first example let's just
take my own resume here I'm going to
upload my own resume this is going to
upload the file into Amazon ews S3 and
then within a few seconds here we can
see that it's hosted on resell and you
can see that a chat is created with my
resume and we're able to see it updated
on the platform and the Magical part is
here I can ask any question and you will
have the context of this entire PDF so
let's say I ask a question like where uh
did Elliot intern at question mark so
I'm going to zoom in a little so you can
see so when I press enter right we can
see that there will be a streaming
response back from open AI itself and he
says that other internet relevate
Technologies right and this is correct
if you see up in the PDF I did internet
this company called relevate
Technologies so it's able to get the
context of this entire PDF and feed it
into open AI itself and usually we can't
do that because if we try to fit in the
entire document it might it might exceed
the token count for gbt like charge gbt
if you try to paste this entire PDF into
it in my overflow and you won't be able
to respond to you but in this case it's
able to take in the context so let's ask
you another question like um uh what are
some projects that he did that
he did question mark so I sent it and
we'll be using for cell AI SDK for this
streaming AI effect so he's able to list
out the PDF and all of this chat logs
are saved into the database so let's
take another function let's take another
example on how this uh platform can
actually be potentially useful so one a
good use case for this PDF function is
let's say I come to any documentation
site so let's say I'm in the Versa
documentation right I have this page
here but I don't read through it and I
actually want to ask a GPD to interact
with this right because the issue is
that charge gbt if you go to the charge
GBP website the information are outdated
meaning that whatever you ask the
chatgibility has only been trained on
data up to I think it was uh 2021
September or something so it doesn't
have updated information about the
updated technology documentation so if I
were to ask about a new feature of a
cell 3gbt won't be able to answer that
accurately you'll have loosen it so what
I can do is I come down to that
documentation I press command P I can
save this entire file look I can save
this entire file into a PDF I'm going to
press save
okay and I'm able to upload this PDF
onto my chat on my chat PDF platform so
I'm going for you to save and after that
I can come here I'm gonna upload my uh
CDs Edge runtime for cell docs I'm going
to upload it onto the platform and it
will basically allow me to interact with
the latest information from whatever
document I want so I can ask like what
is the result age runtime about question
mark
so I'm gonna send this and you can see
that this uh information here is pulling
directly from uh is pulling directly
from the document itself so it does not
hallucinate right it doesn't hallucinate
so that's another good thing about this
entire platform here right so we will
see that it's able to pull in the latest
information so not only is this a really
useful uh platform in a very useful
platform I'm going to teach you how to
build this entire thing from scratch
right and actually well there's one more
feature on the Showcase is that uh by
default we can actually limit this
platform so that users uh when they sign
in they can only upload three PDFs and
then we will be able to teach you how to
integrate the stripe API so we can see
menu subscription we are able to uh use
stripe to allow them to pay money or pay
a monthly subscription 20 a month and
they're able to use this platform
unlimited so I'm gonna be teaching you
how to do the stripe integration and
you're actually able to deploy this SAS
product and eventually make a business
on it if you want to improve on this
platform so we'll be allowing a lot of
things today so there's two main parts
of the tech stack the normal Tech stack
for the full stack will be using next
year's 13.4 we'll be using a click
authentication right so it's a new uh
authentication library that makes a
Google authentication all type of
authentication super easy right uh we'll
be using drizzle orm and a neon DB so
neon DB is a new uh it's a not new but
it's a serverless postgres database uh
so we'll be using that instead and we'll
be using the newest kit on the Block 300
RM so this is um in in comparison to
Prisma DB right Prisma is now or M but
this one be using drizzle and I'll
actually explain why we're going to use
drizzle later on the obviously will be
using stripe API for the assess product
integration and lastly we'll be
uploading all our files to AWS S3 so
I'll teach you how to use the S3 bucket
also this is for the file storage
for the AI textile I'll be teaching you
how to use pinecon DB Lang chain openai
and the new version AI SDK so I'll be
going in depth on how to actually use
these tools to actually create that
custom context PDF thing and so pinecon
DB is a DB to store a vector embeddings
of all documents Lang chain is what ties
together the open Ai and the pine cone
DB and open your eyes obviously the gbt
model that actually creates a large
language model for us to use so explain
a lot more in depth later on so we just
need to know that I'll be teaching you
how to use this text tag so the new main
Concepts that I want to teach in this
video is the age runtime environment so
what's H runtime uh the H run time is if
you connect to exactly the Versa docs
the resources now so the H1 time is in
comparison to the normal node.js
environment so action time is let me
drive by this explanation so imagine
this whole thing is the globe it's the
whole world right and let's say I have
these two continents Asian America
obviously they are not to scale and the
other conditions but I'll just
demonstrate something so a normal let's
say when you deploy a normal function a
normal endpoint to versl or normal a
server the server will leave somewhere
in the world that you choose that is
closest to your users so let's say a lot
of your users are close to Asia you
ideally set up your server in Asia so
that whoever whoever makes requests to
the server will be able to quickly get
the response back so to ensure the best
user experience however what if America
the someone from America wants to make a
request to your server is to travel all
the way down to South Asia and then get
the response back so you'll make the
whole experience very slow
so that's the traditional uh server
serverless environmenting
so what the age runtime does is instead
of packaging up uh and uh deploying the
server to only one location it actually
is able to duplicate the code and
actually uh deploy the the execution
environment onto cdns so
content delivery networks meaning there
are small machines that is distributed
all around the world right and basically
it allows for very fast user experience
so whenever whatever your users are they
are able to find a server a CDN that's
closest to them and so when they make
the request no matter what you are in
the world it's going to be super fast so
why the trade-off of being able to
deploy all around the world and making
it super fast the trade-off is that each
runtime usually have a smaller a smaller
package size meaning let's say we come
back to the age run time let's look at
their trade-off so each function run on
each runtime right so the age runtime
does not expose all the node apis
meaning right the power of node.js is
that it has a lot of packages on npm
right so you're able to use all the npm
packages on the normal serverless
environment right but if you're using
the eight runtime you're sacrificing the
speed for uh you're sacrificing the
packages for the speed so there will be
a lot of restriction in terms of the the
apis that you're able to use but if you
sacrifice that and you use their
supported apis like the fetch API and
the request response all this if you're
able to sacrifice that you're able to
get a very very fast uh response time
for your application right so the reason
why I brought up the age runtime is
because today I'll be teaching you how
to deploy all your AI services on the
edge runtime so open AI has actually uh
created a lot of initiative and a lot of
these are different packages especially
the Versa SDK they have started a lot of
initiatives to move these AI packages up
to the edge to make it age compatible
meaning that a lot of these AI
applications will be able to run on the
edge
right furthermore the reason why we
chose drizzle RM is because orm is
compatible on the edge right so I don't
think Prisma Prisma DB is still
compatible on the edge therefore we are
not able to use prismarck for this
project so I'll be teaching you how to
use Json orm for to interact with your
database
then the second New Concept I want to
check is the retrieval augmented
generation so this is a
so rag a retrieval augmented generation
is a concept within a large language
model right it's AI framework for
retrieving facts from an external
knowledge base to to ensure that the
last language model have accurate
information so instead of the tech gbd
just hallucinating up information we're
able to give it a certain context in
this case the PDF such is able to
generate accurate up to the information
so that's what a retrieval augmented
generation is within the context of this
project so I'll be going much more in
depth on how to build the proper uh rag
framework for our application all right
so with that let's actually begin the
development of this platform so the
first thing here what I'm going to do is
anger come out and open up our terminal
and let's initialize a new next shares
project by doing MPX uh create Dash next
app at Leaders with a typescript flag so
let's press enter and you can ask us for
the project name so let's call it um
chats BDF uh chat PDF Dot Dash YouTube
so we're using eslint CSS we're going to
be using the source directory and this
is the new 13.4 app router uh we're
gonna leave everything as a default and
we can wait for you to install and then
we'll come back soon okay so after we
have initialized the project let's
actually CD into the chat PDF that's
YouTube and let us open up in our code
editor by doing code dot which will open
up in vs code okay so the first thing
here what I'm going to do is let me open
my terminal and let's just do npm run
Dev so that we can make sure that the
project is up and running so let me come
back to our browser I'm going to open up
localhost 3000. so I'm gonna try to
develop it on the alongside here or move
it to the right of the screen and open
up my vs code here okay awesome so right
now we have our next GS 13.4 project up
and running okay so the first step I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna come down to my
directory so under the source we can see
that there's a new app folder here and
how the routing Works within next year's
13 uh 13.4 is that under the app router
right this is page.tsx is a special file
whenever you name the page of txx it's
gonna look at the file structure of it
and determine the root layout so right
now this page.dsx lives at the at the
root app folder therefore it is mapped
to this uh Slash uh Slash root okay so
this app adopted TSX actually
corresponds to this page so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna delete everything
here
and let me just return a normal uh H1
right that says hello world
and let's give you a class name of a
text rate 600 to test out uh Towing CSS
so if you save it we can see that now it
works all right that's good so now that
Towing CSS is set up let us actually set
up a chat CN so uh shed CN is a
component Library that's built on top of
Towing CSS so it's based on Radix UI
which is a accessibility Library so if
you come to Radix UI we can see that it
is a
uh it's a it's a component library that
gives that gives you the accessibility
features of the box right but these are
installed that means that by default
Radix UI is not stock components so
tools to add apply star on it that's
where chat scene comes in Social uses
tone CSS to style those accessible
components for us to use all right so to
actually start using chat CN we'll come
down to our open a new terminal instance
so I'll speed this terminal here and let
me just move this to the side and let us
do MPX chat uh CN Dash UI Dash UI at
liters we're gonna do init so it's going
to initialize the configuration for our
styling so we'll be using typescript
I'll be using the default uh the default
uh default style we'll leave the base a
color access slate and for globals.css
if you come down to our directory
we can see that under this app we got
this globals.css right I'm gonna delete
this so because one shot CN to control
our our styling needs I'm gonna delete
this globals of CSS then I'm going to
come down to my I'm going to come down
to my terminal and I'm gonna enter it's
asking where's my globals.css so I'll do
slash Source slash app says globals.css
so it's going to replace the global CSS
that we have
so we'll be using CSS variables and our
tailwind.config we can see that it lives
at the root here termin.config.ts so
let's just enter Tailwind
.config.ts and lastly we'll leave the
import areas for components and utilus
as as it is I'll be using react server
components and proceed to write the file
the configuration to components.json
okay so let me just refresh the page
okay so right now we can see that
everything's working fine okay so let me
close it now so sharesian has uh has
created a components.json here that uh
contains all configurations for our set
CN components it has also created our
globals.css which includes the Tailwind
Styles and also the set CN uh default
CSS variables here
and lastly we can see that he created a
new lib folder and under he has created
youtube.ts for us and this is just a
Tailwind utility class uh function so
that we can actually use conditional uh
telling styling much more easier so I'll
go to how to use this function on later
on
and lastly he has created a components
for the followers so to begin using chat
scene let's render out the pattern okay
so to create to install the button how
it works is you have to come down to
your terminal and whenever you want to
use a new component from section you
have to do MPX chat a CN Dash UI at
latest add button so you have to add
individual components right so this
ensure that whatever components that you
don't need from will not be installed so
I can press y to install the components
into R4 for folder if I come back to my
directory we can now see that under the
components folder I have a new UI folder
this UI is going to contain all the chat
CN components so this way of section
defines the button for us we don't need
to actually touch this file we just need
to know that it exists and we can use it
so how do I actually use this button
from so let's come back to our page so
instead of returning a hello world I'm
going to return a button so we can see
actually type out the button will be
imported from component slash UI search
button so you can press enter to Auto
Import and I can just say click me
I'm Gonna Save it and now we can see
that this is properly configured so
that's excellent
all right next up let's set up clock
authentication so in our original uh
application we can see that uh this all
the authentication is handled by clerk
so I can sign out right and this is
manage and if I want to actually uh log
in I can press log in to get started so
then this will lead us to the clerk
signing page so I can sign up with
GitHub about Google so in this case I
understand continue with GitHub then
basically it will lead me back to my
home page and I'll be able to get my
user information
and then we can see that he has brought
us back to the Arduino application so to
set up clock let us go to uh research
clock auth and then it should be the
first link so clerk.com so I can move
this to the site first
so the first step here is let us
actually log in so if you have not
created account please do so after you
have done that we can actually come to
our
uh let's just zoom out and then we can
go to that the console the dashboard so
let's press the dashboard
and then we can come in and create a new
application so click on ADD application
and in this case let's name it to chat
PDF Dash YouTube
okay uh Dash YouTube so you can choose
how your users will sign in in this case
I'm gonna toggle off email address right
so we just want to allow them to use
Google
or GitHub so you can help however you
want your Microsoft whatever you want so
I'm gonna just choose this tool for
demonstration purposes then we'll click
on create application so let me just uh
split my screen again so
now that we got the A publishical
publishable and secret key we have to
copy this to uh environment variables
intel.env file so come back to your
directory and at the base of your
directory let's create a new DOT EnV
file to store all our environmental
variables right so one more thing just
in case we forget let's go into our git
ignore and then let us enter our EnV so
we don't want git to actually track our
EnV file so we don't push this
environment variables up to GitHub so
save the git talk okay you know and now
we can copy this uh these two lines of
code into the environment so this will
Define the two uh clerk API keys for us
to use so let's save the EnV and we'll
close it up now let's press continue in
dock so that we can follow their
instruction so we'll be using club with
next year so we can just follow this so
let me just close this out so the first
step here is actually to install their
package so let's npm install add clerk
Dash uh nextgs so let's install that so
then the second step is to and put the
environment cues which we have already
done so so now that the third step is
actually to mount this club provider so
what I'm gonna do is once it has
finished install I'm gonna come out to
my layout.tsx all right so under my
layout.txx uh I am going to basically
put in the cloud provider so here I'm
gonna do a few things first so right now
we can see that okay it has finished
installing so in my layer.tsx this this
file is the one that wraps my entire
application so you can see these
children these children represents my
employer application so whatever
metadata here we can add we can wrap
this entire application here so for this
metadata I'm going to delete the
description so for the title here this
corresponds to whatever title you see on
the tab itself so I'm going to name it
to chats PDF uh YouTube
so if I save it now you can see that the
tab title has updated
then under here I'm gonna add the clip
provider right so the first thing I'm
going to do is let me see if I can Auto
Import so I'm going to import Club
provider so it isn't Auto Import so
let's just uh manually import the
provider from add clerk slash nextges so
clock provider
provider and then I'm gonna wrap my
entire application application with this
cloud provider
okay then I'm Gonna Save it so after
adding so after adding this cloud
provider so let's see what else we need
to do so we have wrapped the entire
cloud provider and lastly here is we
need to protect our application so we
need to create this middleware.ts file
so come down to our folder and under in
our Direction uh in our source folder so
under Source create a file called middle
where dot TS right so this middleware.ts
is a special file right such that uh in
here we can Define code that will run
before every routes right so let's say
you navigate to a route to sash home or
search API chat right before you hit the
endpoint the code within this middleware
file will run first so let's just copy
it in the the code from code we'll copy
in so let me explain why it does so this
config right uh that specifies the
matches so this matter is basically a
bunch of regex to specify when this uh
middleware should run so it will run
whenever we are hitting a slash endpoint
or whenever we hit like search API with
a star character so these uh array will
basically dictate when this code will
run and then here this is the auth
middleware that's imported from clerk
right so this file this code here will
actually then uh run the necessary logic
to protect our Roots so by right right
now all the roots are private so I
cannot even access a slash I cannot
access the slash so now if I save it
here and I refresh the page to see that
it should redirect me to the page
because it's a protected route and in
this case it does right so we can see
that it's redirected to their uh to
their hosted domain right and it's
asking us to sign in to our chat PDF
that's YouTube right so we actually want
to make the slash route into a public
log so what I'm going to do then is I'm
going to come down here into our off
middleware so within this off middle way
I can pass in some options so one of the
objects is the public route public route
is an array so I can Define what routes
I want to be public in this case I'm
going to just specify the slash root to
be public so then when I come back here
to my localhost 3000 instead of taking
me to the sign in page I'll be uh I'll
be authorized to visit this show so this
is a public group so I do have to be
locked I don't have to be logged in in
order to view this page okay so now that
we have set up a clock let's actually
begin creating the home page here all
right so I'm gonna just uh start out the
diff so the first thing here is actually
to mark it async so this async will make
sure that it's a server component so
this entire code block is going to run
once on the server to generate the HTML
code then this HTML code is going to be
directly sent back to the client for it
to be rendered so this is a server
component so I'm gonna just return a few
return uh the first thing here is to
create the upper the outer div
it's going to have a width of a screen
and the minimum minimum height of a
screen and also let's create a bit the
background grader so I searched up
terwin CSS BG gradient and basically I
found this website called hyper color
that basically gives you all these
options for gradients and you're able to
customize it and copy the Tailwind CSS
to your file itself so I've already
found one that I like so I'm going to
paste it in here so it's gonna be VG
desk gradient
tool right
from rows 100 to
sorry 2 100 so if we save it now we got
this nice background going on here so
within this div Let's uh Auto div that
centers everything in the center so
we'll do absolute position absolute
we'll give you a top of half left of
half then offset it back by negative
translate half and I give Translate
y of half
so this will Center anything within it
into the center of the screen so that's
nice so now let's actually create the
the text so within this div let's have a
new uh diff called Flex Flex uh column
we'll have items of Center and text off
center
okay
within this div let us create a diff
right with a class name of flags and
items
the center within here we have a hit run
that says chat with any PDF so let's
save it first we'll give this H1 a
column of marginal of three types of 5xl
and font of semi gold so let's save it
and now we have a nice title showing up
here
below the H1 I'm gonna show the user
button so now we can see that there's
this user button whenever I'm signed in
that shows my information and I can
manage my account and this is a
component provided by clerk itself that
I can sign out also so this component is
called user button right I can import it
from a clerk assess next year's itself
right so we'll import that and we can
pass in one option for after sign out
URL so whenever they click sign up where
do you want to redirect them to so I'm
going to redirect them back to the
original URL so it's the same page
basically so let's save it so right now
we can see that nothing shows because
we're not signing so this user button
will only show when you're signed in
okay so that's normal so then below uh
below this div that shows a chat with
any PDF let's create another uh diff
called flex and give a margin top of two
all right within here will show up uh
we'll show a button
a button that says go to chats so let's
save it first right so this button will
show so that they are able to go to
their chats if they are signed in so
actually how do you check whether they
are signed in so actually click also
provides us with another very nice
utility function called cross so you can
import this all function from clerk
right we'll invoke it so we have to
await the the call here first and we'll
be able to get back uh user ID
so I'm able to get a lot of different
things right but one of these things is
the user ID so if the login this user ID
will resolve to a string right it's
either a string or no but if it's now
that means they are not authenticated so
you can buy into a variable code is a
cons
is off this would be a double negation
of user ID so if it is not now if it is
now this will turn into a Boolean and
this is Earth now is a Boolean itself
because it's Boolean so it's whether
they are logged in or not so underneath
here we actually want to only show this
if their authentication if they're
authenticated so if they're
authenticated then we let them go to the
chats page so right now we're not
authenticated therefore is hidden okay
so that's good so then underneath uh
this div let us have a paragraph tag
that just says join uh millions of
students
uh researchers and professionals to
instantly answer questions and
understand
research with
AI
so let's see if that it's just a nice
tech line below it so let's give this
paragraph text I'm starting so we'll
give you a Max width of excel much in
terms of uh two text of large and tax
slates off
600. so if we see that we got a nice
darling here so actually just let me
change it to margin top of one because I
think it's a bit too big right now
imagine half one okay that's good then
underneath the paragraph tag right so we
still uh just above the three closing
tags let's have a new div that is a
width of full and margin top of four
okay
so this uh this uh part here is going to
be what is gonna be the file upload page
right so I'm gonna just check
if it's off so if they're authenticated
right then it makes sense for me to show
a
combinator
however if they are not authenticated
let us actually link them to the sign in
page so I'm going to import this link
from next slash link
and within this link let us just have a
button
a button that says login to get started
so this link component is gonna have a
head draft to slash sign up sign in
so let's leave it so I still haven't
created this sign in root right so I'm
going to create that soon and this
sign-in page is basically a clerk pick
so that they're able to see and log in
with their Google or GitHub right so log
in to get started and let me just uh add
a icon just below this button right so
within this button let me add a
a component called log in so uh
for the components that are actually in
download
the package called npm install Lucid
Dash react so this ducid react is
basically a react package that gives us
a lot of nice icons for us to use
so let me just do log in again so let me
just import it manually right so import
from lucid
Lucid Dash react okay and then there
should be a login component here
log in icon
so let me just uh import it log
in and let's save this and right now we
can see that there's a nice button here
so let me just dial it a little so let's
give you a width of four high of 4 and a
margin left of two
okay so now it looks much nicer okay so
then finally
this div we can add an image so in case
you want to showcase like your
application product you can just add a
screenshot of your image down here so
just in case for demonstration I won't
edit here but it's a really simple
function to add
okay so now let's actually create the
login root right so one more thing we
need to add right is if we come down to
our uh come back to our EnV file we can
actually Define a few things for Cook to
take into consideration so let's come
back to uh cook.com and let's actually
view the documentation again so I'm
gonna come back to my I'll come back to
my console so I'm going to expand this
out a little bit more so come back to
our dashboard let me explain this so
dashboard and come back to our uh cook
PDF that's YouTube and that's coming on
to our
uh
continuing Docs so we've already set up
the provider we've protect our
application so last thing here is
actually to create the environment
variables to Define where I will sign in
and sign up pages are so I'm gonna copy
these four variables into my EnV file
over here so I'm going to copy it just
below here right so let me just uh add a
comment that says this is for the clerk
clerk environment variables all right so
with this uh four applications four
variables so it defines well assigning
Pages where I'll sign up pages and where
to go after we have signed in and signed
up okay so we'll just leave it as
default so if you want to change it
let's say you want to bring them to a
dashboard after they have signed in you
can just easily change it to
slash.jsport and then whenever uh signs
you in it will automatically navigate
you to dashboard
so let's save it so how do we actually
create this sign in false right so if
you come up to our fifth step here right
we can build our own sign in and sign up
pages so let's come down to our
directory so the first step is come down
to our app folder and let's create a
folder called sign Dash up
within this sign up query of now folder
called uh double square brackets dot dot
dot sign Dash up
then within this folder let's create the
page.tsx
we can just import the sign up component
from Kirk itself so this sign up
component has it has the pre-style from
Quirk itself so let me save that and let
us do the same for the sign in page so
come down to our app
and let us create a new folder called
sign Dash in
within it let's create the dot dot sign
in uh wow card and then let's create
page
.tsx so page.tsx is a special file name
so we'll do the same for the sign in
we'll import it from clerk itself and
just return it
okay so now that everything is uh
completed if you come back to our
YouTube and we can see that when we
hover over it we can see that it's being
brought us to our sign in page so let me
click on it and by right it should bring
us to our slash sign in and is basically
showing us this a default we are showing
this default component from Kirk so let
me just uh Center this component in the
center so I'm going to just return a
wrapping div with a position absolute
okay so I'm going to wrap this into sign
in so let's have this our costume of
absolute top of half left of half and I
give translates X of half negative
Translate Y of puff
so let me sign uh save it and now we can
see the signing page is brought to the
bottom so I'm gonna delete this
semicolon so then we can press continue
with GitHub or we can go to the sign up
page so you come back to the sign up
page we are showing the sign up screen
here so I'm gonna do the same I'm gonna
copy over this div to our signup page
right so I'm going to just wrap this
entire thing
and then within here let me just close
this div and then now it's also centered
so I'm gonna sign in with my uh just
Google account continue with Google and
we can choose which account to sign in
with and by right this should navigate
us back to our slash page
so now we can see that we have been
signed in
right so now we can see that our user
button being shown here and we can see
that since we are logged in the file
upload component is being shown so
that's perfect okay so now that we have
set up clock where now we can see that
we can manage our account and even sign
up so there's all these functionalities
are provided by clerk in a very simple
to use API okay so the next step here is
actually let us set up our database so
for the database you'll be using a neon
DB so come down to Neon DB right we can
see that neon is a serverless uh
branchible postgres database I'm gonna
open it here a bit more so to actually
create the database so you have to sign
sign up or sign in so I actually sign up
with my GitHub account so I can sign in
so underneath the project where you get
one free project for this database so
you just have to come down and press
create new project
so for the name let me just name it as
chat PDF that's YouTube
for just postgres version just leave it
and for the region choose one that is
nearest to you in this case I'm going to
choose Singapore for the rest just leave
the configurations default and just
press create project
so now we can see that the the project
has been created and the database is
also being created for us really quickly
so now just need to save this uh they
save this string to our environmental
variables so copy whatever database URL
you have here
come down to your uh vs code Captain to
your dot EnV file and below here let me
just initialize this variable called
database uh data base Dash underscore
URL and let's just post uh let's just uh
paste it so make sure there's no white
lines and make sure there's no white
spacers behind Okay so one more thing
here you might need to add is come down
here at the end right you need to add
this
uh
you have to add a config called SSL
require so let me just check here uh
yeah so we're gonna add one question
mark and just do SSL mode equals to
require so this is just for uh this so
that our connection is secure and so
that our drizzle orm is able to connect
to our neon database so after you're
done just save it and close it back out
okay so now that we have our neon setup
let's close it close the tab we don't
need it anymore and now let's actually
set up the drizzle RM so if we are not a
sure what result is
orm is a typescript object relational
mapper so once the object relation
mapper it's just a way for you to
interact with our database without using
SQL so it also gives us that type safety
and makes dealing with database calls
much easier
and why we chose drizzle or I'm over
prisoners that Prisma is known to be a
much slower and also Prisma is not age
compatible and in this case drizzle or
Amazon new new RM that is Edge
compatible so let's actually set up set
it up so and go under your file
directory and we need to create a new uh
a library for this a lip so come under
your lip and let us create a database
folder so click name DB and within this
DB folder in the lip folder create a new
file called index.ts
okay so this is where we can set up our
drizzle RM so the first thing here we
need to actually install the drizzle
packages right so let me just close it
and open our terminal and let's install
the drizzle by doing npm install a
drizzle Dash or M
okay and then we need one more thing we
need the Ampere install at neon data
base slash server serverless so this is
for the adapter between the neon and
also our drizzle RM so while waiting for
that to deploy to install let's come
down to our index.ts so the first thing
here is actually let's import a few
things from add neon database serverless
so we need the actual neon function for
to connect to our database and then also
we need a neon config so we can set Neo
config.fetch connection cache equals to
true so that it caches the connections
that's being set and then underneath
that that's actually a check so if
we do have a database URL so if not
process.env DOT database underscore URL
we can just throw
an error
a new error that says a GB database URL
is not found so if that if we have a
database URL then we can connect the SQL
the server using the neon function and
we can connect it to our
process.env.database URL okay then
underneath here we can just do export
cons DB so this DB of variable is what
is going to be used to interact with our
database so we can call functions uh
like select select star from whatever
table we want so this DB will be calling
drizzle so this drizzle let's import it
so import
so let's just move it down here so
import uh from
drizzle orm slash neon http
okay so we need to ins uh just import
the drizzle function so this drizzle is
going to take in SQL and then we need a
schema file so we need a schema because
this schema defines the shape of our
database so let me save this in index.ts
come down to your folder again we need
this DB a file let's create a schema.ts
okay so this schema.ts is gonna where
all our our table definitions are gonna
go right so the first thing is I'm going
to import a few things from
the drizzle RM Dash PG core so PG core
stands for postgres core so it's going
to contain a lot of different utilities
uh from postgres database so it contains
things like integer or like a PG table
so we need a PG table function
and we also uh let's actually create a
let's actually start creating the tables
so for the data model right we need a
first thing we need is a chat so a chat
table the chat table is gonna contain uh
this individual stuff so if you go to
chats we can see that each chat is an
individual role within the database so
when we go into chess we can see that we
have all these chats right 10 plus chats
each chat is going to be one row within
a database so each tab will contain the
name of the PDF the URL to the PDF uh
the user ID related whoever created the
chat and also uh whatever chats that
it's gonna hold so let's create that so
the first thing here is we can export
cons uh chats right it's gonna be a new
PG table of new postgres table it's
gonna have a chats a name within the
database itself right and then for the
second function the second uh parameter
here's where we can Define The Columns
for this postgres table so this is just
how the drizzle RM works so we're gonna
have ID right this is going to be a
Serial so we can import Zero from uh PG
core right make sure it's imported from
PG core right
we have a column name of ID and we'll
make this a primary key okay then we'll
have a PDF name right so this PDF name
is what is shown here in the sidebar
right this is going to be um let's put
it as a text so this text also comes
from a PG core
it's gonna be named PDF name and we'll
set it as not now so make sure that this
name cannot be now
we have a PDF URL which is also mapped
to a text of PDF URL and we make sure
this is not now also however created add
field right this is going to be a
timestamp field from PG core itself
and we'll just make sure it is not now
and also we can default it default to
now so whenever we create it's gonna
default this as a column to the
timestamp now
a user ID field so this us ID will be
pointing to the uh clerk user ID so
let's just put it as um varchar so this
vars are also from PG core so let's say
me as user ID we can give you a length
of let's say 256 characters and make
sure that this is not now also
lastly we need a foul key
a file key which is gonna be just a
text field
and when you make file key and make sure
it's not known so this file key is for
when we are retrieving uh the file from
S3 so you can see that we have this PDF
PDF thing right so this PDF maps to a
resource within the S3 bucket so we can
use this file key to actually ID the
file within S3
so after you have chats let's also
create a messages so we can see that
each uh each um housing each message
let's say I come down to our uh Versa
for cell docs right we can see that each
message here will be saved to a database
so we can also create that table
so let's export a cons messages it's
gonna be a postgres table let's name it
messages within the database
and then for the columns we'll have ID
which will be a serial
of ID and the same as primary key
okay then we have chat ID so each
message will belong to a chat so this is
how we form the uh one-to-many relations
so this is going to be an integer so
this from PG core itself
we'll name it chat ID and then it's
going to have dot references so this is
how we use the references variable
within or visual RM so what is the
reference in taking a callback function
and it just Returns the chats.id so this
is how we make sure that this chat ID
actually does a foreign key reference
back to this chats.id
okay and make sure that it's not now
also and then we have a Content so this
is a message content let's name it as a
text
uh name it content and make sure that
it's not now
okay
then uh two more things we need the
created ad so it's gonna be the same up
here so it's gonna be a timestamp not
now and also defaults to the current
timestamp and lastly we need a row so
this row can either be a user or a
system so we want to create an enum for
that so to create Edom we actually come
up here and do export cons
user system uh enum
so this could be a PG enum from PG core
itself right so we're gonna name it a
user underscore system Dash enum so this
is going to be the mapping within the
database itself and here we can pass in
an array of what we want the enum to be
so this will lock in the field so that
it can either be from a system or from
the user so if the row here is a system
that means that this message is being
sent by gbt if the Euro has user right
then we know it's a user message so we
can just make this a type mod type save
by creating an enum within it so for
this row you'll just be a user system
enum limit row right and then we'll set
it as not now okay you can also set a
default uh value right we can see that
it gives us the intellisense to either
system or user okay so now that we have
all this we can just uh save the file
okay so now that we have saved the file
how do we actually make sure that this
uh schema here is pushed up to the neon
database right so for that we actually
need another tool from drizzle it's
called drizzle kit right so there's two
things there's two parts to drizzle
right there's the drizzle orm package
itself this drizzle RM is what is
interacting with our database but
there's also a a drizzle drizzle kit a
package this drizzle kit provides us
with utility functions to create
migrations and to make sure that all our
database is synced up with this schema
here okay so with that let's actually
install the drizzle kit so mpm install
uh drizzle dash kit
so let's install that so this drizzle
kit will allow us to push it up so one
more thing that we need is that uh in
our in our folder here in our root
folder let us actually create that
actually let's save this schema first
and then in our root folder let's create
a result
dot config.ts so this config.ts is going
to hold the drizzle configuration on how
we want to to tell diesel well Sigma
file lives in so the first thing here it
says import a type uh called from
drizzle kit itself so this type will
import as config so they give us some
type annotations for the configuration
object okay okay then after here
we need to export a default
configuration object and we can see that
satisfy config right so this uh this uh
this make this object make sure that it
will certify config and if we press Ctrl
space we get all these different uh type
annotations as to what configurations
are available so the first thing we need
is the driver the driver is going to be
a PG postgres right the second thing
here is we need the schema so this this
uh this variable will tell this drizzle
kit where the schema actually lives in
so that whenever we push our schema
right So eventually we can run a command
within our terminal called MPX drizzle
dash kit
push PG so this will take a look at our
schema and then make sure that our
database in neon is synced up with our
schema so to tell it the schema let us
actually do uh dot slash source so it's
taking from the current path itself so
it's going to go into our source folder
come in the source folder come with our
lip folder into DB to schema.ts so make
sure that whatever file here matches
your uh your file structure should be
under slash Source lib slash DB
schema.ts
all right and then lastly we need a DB
credentials
we need this DB credentials right we
have a connection screen a connection
string and this one we want to get it
from process.even
env.database URL Okay so uh linux.js
actually doesn't provide this EnV here
right now because
right now to observe that you see inside
this Source all the files within this
Source folder will have access to the
EnV variable however any folders any
file sets outside this Source folder
will not have access to the process.env
database URL that's defined within.env
right so to actually load this dot EnV
we actually need to install our package
called mpm install dot EnV so with this
in the EnV package we can load the EnV
file into our process.env so let's just
import Star as dots EnV from dot EnV
then we'll call Dot env.config
right we'll pass the path to B dot EnV
so basically what this does is it will
look at this dot EnV file that lives in
the same direction here so you can see
the EnV it's going to load all these
variables including this process those
database URL it's going to load it into
this file and then we can access this
process.inv.database URL
so now that I've completed everything
let's save it okay now you can actually
do the pushing of the schema up to uh
the neon database so I'm gonna do just
do MPX drizzle kit Dash uh drizzle dash
kit we can do push and then specify your
uh your database so be PG stands for
postgres so let's press enter and
hopefully this will be in our uh you see
it's able to read in our diesel
config.ts right and it's going to try to
push so one more thing I forgot when you
actually need to come into our TS config
right sorry
so will you come in about DS convict so
you see this target instead of es5 we
have to move into es6 instead so let's
save it and with that let's actually try
again so let me just uh drizzle kit and
push and now we can see uh changes
applied so why is saying that it has
actually uh push our tables so it has
run out comments like create table and
just push it up to our neon so to make
sure that it has work right I can
actually come out to uh the terminal and
I can do MPX drizzle dash kit studio so
this will open up in a studio itself so
PG is not imported so we need to install
this PG package also so npm install PG
so these are drizzle kit studio will
open up a in-browser database client for
you so let's try again so let's open the
studio and now you can see that the
sudos up and running on this port so
let's open this port okay let's open it
here open in our browser
you can see that it is it has this uh it
has a nice interface for us to interact
with our user models so if you come down
here we can see that the chats and
messages table has been created so these
chats are messages we can see that the
schema this chat ID content creator add
is coming from our schema.ts so we have
made sure that all our schema have been
properly migrated up to the neon
database so that's perfect yes
everything is up and running and we are
good to go so let me just close this
drizzle studio and then we can continue
working on the other parts
okay so that's excellent so now that we
have set up drizzle and our database
let's actually create the file upload
component that we see here this job PDF
function here so I'm going to explain it
a little bit here let me just collapse
our terminal clear up everything so
let's actually create a new component uh
kernel combo Source come down to our
components let's create a new component
called a file upload dot TSX so this is
going to house our thought output
component so I'm going to initialize it
by doing a TS rafce so uh this snippet
is from a is from an extension so let me
search out the extension I think it's
called Uh es7 uh en7 Snippets or
something uh es7 react Snippets es7
react Redux uh Snippets so this a
snippet give us the ability to just type
in uh tsrefc a general is the reaction
react component for us okay so uh for
this file upload here it's not gonna
taking any props it's not taking any
props right and this is gonna be a
client component so let's put this use
Clan so if you if you're not sure so
this uh for any component that requires
interactivity like on click function on
a button or let's say you're trying to
drag in a file that basically renders uh
on the client and then it requires you
to use date all right so let's say if
you're using a function that are using a
component that requires uh the use the
use State function from ux then we have
to convert this into a client component
okay so that this component will be
rendered on the clan so to actually uh
create this styling so we need to
install a library called uh mpm install
react uh react
drop zone so this will create that uh
that file upload dropping uh drop
utility for us
so with that uh Drop Zone installed
let's actually import it so import
um
use Drop Zone sorry use Drop Zone
from react Dash Drop Zone okay so let's
actually create the styling for this
right so for this I'm gonna just return
a normal div with a class name of
padding of two background white and
rounded XL so let me save it first and
let's just import the component into our
page so come back to our app.tsx so
whoever we see this file upload I'm just
going to import the file upload so I
upload file is it file uploads um okay
it's file upload so import it from our
components so let's save it and now we
can see that we have a component that's
showing up here so right now it's this
BT white that is showing So within this
diff let's actually start it properly
okay so we'll have another div all right
uh within this div we're gonna actually
store uh our file input so we have an
input uh input variable here input in
component and then actually let us also
destructure a few things from the react
drop zone so that we can properly style
it so we actually need the structure a
few things from use Drop Zone Itself by
calling it so why is it going to return
it's gonna return us with two things get
root props and also get input props so
these two props we have to pass into our
input input field and our sort of div
fuel such that you have the proper props
to handle the file upload okay so within
this uh within this inner div right so
we have this inner div let's pass in the
dot dot dot get root props just invoke
it and for this input we assume you're
passing dot uh get input props invoke it
and save it so right now it doesn't show
up yet but uh let me try pressing on it
okay see it doesn't show up so for this
div for this get root props let's pass
in an object we can pass in more
attributes basic class name so we can
properly style this class uh this diff
properly so let's give you a border of a
dash so yes the dash border look boulder
dash 2 rounded XL cursor pointer
that's why we hover over it right BG
gray or 50.
passing one of eight
uh let's give you a flex justify Center
items send items that Center
and then let's give you a flex
call
so let's save it and now we have this
nice input box here so when we hover
over it you can see it turns Our concern
to this cursor pointer and if you click
on it by right by right it should show
this input field okay so it opens up our
file explorer which is good okay so then
underneath the input here uh we want to
show show a thing here so let us create
a fragment and let us upload a inbox
inbox so this inbox icon from Lucid
react let's give you a style of width of
10 high of 10 text blue of 500
text blue or 500 and below the inbox
let's just have a paragraph tag that
says drop PDF here
let's give you a class name of
margin top of two
tax of small and tax Dash lead Dash 400
so if you save it now we got this drop
PDF here showing up properly okay
so that's good that's good so now let us
actually to add the uh file upload
feature so for this use Drop Zone uh for
this use drop zone right we can pass in
an object so we can pass in some
parameters we need to tell how to behave
so we can accept so we're asking what
type of files do you want to accept from
the users right so it's going to accept
an uh application PDF
right it's gonna accept an array which
is only says P dot PDF
so this is the syntax to actually make
sure that users can only upload dot PDF
files okay and then learn to pass in Max
files of one so they can only upload one
files one file a maximum and then we can
pass in a callback right so we're
passing uh on drop so whenever they drop
a file or when they pass in a file where
you can actually get the accepted files
and let us for now let's just control
the unlock
accepted false
so let me save it so let me open just
explain it a little bit bigger so I'm
going to open up my console here
right so open on Console so let me just
uh clear that out so let's say now we
drop press drop PDF and let's drop uh
see we can see that only PDF files are
allowed so I'm going to edit this and
whenever we drop it you can see now that
we have this array of files so this is
what the accepted files a variable shows
so it's going to be an array of false so
the file that we want is leaving in the
first index and it just contains all the
information like uh the name the path
the size of it and so to type so later
we'll be using this file object to
upload this file onto our AWS S3
all right so now that we have the files
set up let's actually upload it to uh
AWS S3 so to set up the awsg account
come to your just search AWS right and
then just go into Amazon web service
right so cloud computing service and you
want to create an account and log into
the a console dashboard so just press
sign in to console or sign up for the
console if you haven't so you can sign
up with email right so after you have
signed in you have to log in as a root
user and you come back to the console
home so come down the search bar and
just search for S3 so S3 stands for
simple storage service so SSS S3 so
click into it and what I'm going to do
is create a new pocket okay so come down
here and just press create bucket so for
the bucket name just name it whatever
you want but it has to be a unique uh
globally so let's just name it um chat
PDF Dash YouTube
okay uh the region choose one that is
closest to you and make sure you
remember which version you chose so for
me I'm going to choose a Singapore uh
here AP Southeast one so remember this
apself is one
and then uh object ownership just choose
ACS ACL disable
uh yeah
come down to a choose uh uncheck this so
we want to block all public access so
uncheck it and come down here just
acknowledge bucket versioning just
disable and then
uh everything else can be disabled yeah
so advanced settings just leave it as
blank uh as default and so everything
will just leave it as default so now
it's successfully created the bucket so
for now we still need to change
something so we need to actually make
all the objects to be public so come to
chat PDF that's YouTube permissions not
priorities permissions
right uh not Public Access so right now
it's off right underneath a bucket
policy or you press edit right so this
is a Json configuration to make sure
that uh we need to tell people who can
access the of the files that stored in
this bucket all right so for this policy
you want to make sure that everyone can
edit uh not edit but everyone can access
this so just set up an object in here so
they'll have a version right this
version will be
2012.10 17. okay and then for the
Statesman States month right this will
be an array right and the first item in
the real and now object
right so this object will have Sid
of public
read gets object
okay then you have an effect of
allow
they have a principle
of star
and then we have action
of S3 gets object so make sure you got
the spelling and all the capitalization
all correct and lastly we have this
resource these reasons will have
uh this resource will have Arn uh colon
earws colon S3 then three colons then
you have to enter the name of your
bucket so this check the PDF that's
YouTube slash star okay so with that uh
make sure that everything is looks
correct so this has to be resource okay
so after you have saved that just come
down here scroll down and press press
save changes
okay so now our bucket policy has been
updated so without the policy come down
to course so this core subject is
important so that we can actually upload
files from our localhost or from our uh
versus URL so this course we have to go
and edit it and so this is another Json
object to tell uh to tell AWS who can
actually upload files so this is going
to be an array actually so it's going to
be an array bringing the first item in
the array right let us uh put in
allow allowed heaters
there's gonna be an array and let's put
star so next we can allow all the haters
then we need the allowed uh methods to
be
another array of put
post
delete and lastly get
okay so let's style this properly
and then under the allow methods we need
allowed
Origins so this is to make sure that we
can allow different URLs to upload to
the AWS S3 so let's put star so that all
the URLs is able to upload and then we
have lastly expose expose uh headers to
significant empty array so this to make
sure that uh this to make sure that okay
so this get has this code so after
saving this let's press save changes
so this course is important so that we
can properly allow our website to
actually upload files to uh to uh AWS SV
okay so now if you come back to our
buckets okay so now that we have set up
AWS S3 let's actually uh create a
function that accepts the local file
input and uploads to actually itself
okay so let me expand this uh back up
here so come down to your folder and let
us create a under your lip let's create
a new
s3.ts uh so this actually RTS is going
to contain the function to actually load
in the S3 configuration all right so
first we need to install the actual SJ
package so for that will be npm install
AWS SDK so we make sure that we can
interact with the AWS SG buckets
so import uh import uh AWS from AWS SDK
okay then we want to actually
um
just uh initialize the S3 bucket right
to add a initialize S3 uh function
itself so let's let's export um async
sorry export async function
call upload to S3
okay so this uploads actually will
accept a file of this file input so this
is a standard uh web API a file uh type
right so we can accept this file so
later we passed in this file so right
now if you come to file upload we can
see that this accept files is an array
of file so we'll eventually call this
upload to S3 on the this accepted files
input
okay so we're gonna do is to do in put
it in the try catch block okay so first
we can initialize AWS dot config dot uh
update right when you pass in two things
we need to access key ID
access
for the update we need access key ID
right and also we need a secret access
secret uh
access Secrets access key
right so how do we actually get this AWS
secret access key and access key ID so
come back to your actual S3 console
right convert your console right come to
up to Services right you need to search
for some nickel IAM so this stands for
uh identity and access management
so come under the IM service so they
separate from the F3 service that we
have explored within the AWS console all
right so come down to the IM I am
console now we need to add a new uh user
so this user is going to give us that
access to actually access the SG bucket
so then we can create a key pair for
this user and the key pair will be what
is used for this access key ID and
secret access key all right so come to
the sidebar and click on users right
right now we can see that uh we can
create a new user so just press create
user and name it whatever you want can
just chat PDF Dash YouTube S3 okay so
this uh user will be able to access the
S3 bucket right so we don't want to
provide user access because we are just
trying to provide the console access to
a uh just to get the key value we're not
trying to give the access to a person so
uncheck it then press on next
then just have to attach policies
directly so search for S3 and basically
you want to give it Amazon S3 full
access right Amazon actually full access
so check on that box
then lastly just press next
okay so now that we have granted the
full access we can create the user
so after creating the user coming to the
uh the user itself and that way I can
access the key pairs so come down to our
uh
security credentials and let us actually
do access key so create access key so I
want you to choose your just choose
local code for the use case right and
then press understand the above
confirmation and press next
so that you can just give a description
tag if you want in case you can just
leave it blank and create access keys so
right now we can see that we can just
press show so these are two things are
what is needed for the S3 access key ID
so coming to your dot EnV let's actually
paste it in right so we'll create a new
section called uh AWS S3 okay so within
the AWS S3 let us do next public
uh
next public AWS S3 sorry we just put AWS
just naming over one next public S3 uh
access
key ID so I'm gonna pasting this access
key ID here
okay
and then for the next line let's name it
next underscore public underscore S3
underscore Secret
access key
right then let's paste it in here
so the reason why it has to be pre-faced
with next public is because we'll be
accessing these environment variables
from our client right because when we
drop the PDF we'll be uploading the PDF
directly from the next GS client up to
S3 therefore we need these two variables
to be uh public to our client uh client
a component so after we have done that
we can just uh come back to our code
here so save the EnV and so we need
these two variables right so just copy
these two variables and make sure that
you paste it in correctly so for the
access key ID make sure it is next
public S3 access key ID and for the SQL
access key let's copy this in here also
so then paste it here
so this is a secret access key so make
sure the variables match and make sure
you have it uh properly if you
configured within the dot EnV
y so let's save it so after configuring
the AWS object now we can actually get
the S3 object so cons S3 equals to new
AWS new
uh AWS dot S3 okay and then under here
we can actually pass in this program
from Jack these params allow us to
configure our bucket right so remember
the bucket name that we have created we
can just store this in a variable itself
so let me just copy this and let us
create a new EnV variable so next public
S3
bucket
bucket name so just name it as a wobble
you have created in the s3u console in
this case will be for me it's chats PDF
that's YouTube right
so let me save that
then in here I can just access it so
next public S3 bucket name make sure
that it matches so the copy it just in
case
okay so after configuring the program
you need to pass in uh under the param
pass in the region right so this region
uh for me is AP South East one so
remember uh the region that you created
the bucket in so paste I'll just put it
in here this region configuration okay
now lastly we want to Define uh we
actually upload it so we can do cons
upload equals to S3 dot put object
okay this pull object take in a params
so let's actually Define the params here
cons params is going to be an object of
the bucket so the bucket will be the the
S3 bucket name and then we need the key
so this key will be uh the name of the
fossil this key will be identif uh
uniquely identifyable to the file right
so we have this file key here and then
lastly we have a body right with this
actual file that is passed into this
function
so for this key variable let's actually
create a file key variable right so that
let's name it uploads
slash plus dates dot now dot two string
so this to make sure that the file key
is uh uh is uniquely uh ID lastly we'll
do file dot name dot replace replace the
a space with the empty with a hyphen so
this power key basically we want to
upload to our uploads folder within AWS
S3 so we can organize it properly and
then we just want to append the date now
to make sure that it's properly ID
uniquely identified and then we'll just
replace the file name if the if there's
any blank space we just replace it with
a hyphen then this file key we can use
instead of this file name directly so
let's put in the file key okay
perfect so now we can actually upload
this uh params right so after these
params we can do Dot so right now this
params is complaining because that the
bucket could be undefined so we are
ensure that this is this exists so we'll
just put a bank so to reassure that AWS
S3 that this uh the bucket name will
actually be defined okay so then after
we put objects with the params let's do
on we can do a HTTP uh upload progress
right then we can access a event
so whenever s is abdulating let's say
it's a big cloud let's say you are
building like 10 megabytes of PDF right
as it is uploading uploaded to AWS S3
this callback function will be called
and then you're able to monitor the
process and it's able to give us back
like the progress then you're able to
create UI to create a progress bar uh to
show that the file is being uploaded to
S3 so for now let's just do console.log
uh
uploading to S3 dot dot dot and let us
just do pass int uh so we can actually
get the progress by doing
um
let's just do uh events dot loaded right
divided uh even downloaded times 100
divided by events dot total right
and in this pass in we can actually call
The Dot
sorry called The Dot uh dot two string
sorry dot two string
sorry this should be here
okay so we basically let me save this
file so that it's easier to see so we'll
take the env.loaded times 100 so that we
can get it in terms of the percentage uh
divided it by uh the whole the total
file size will convert it to two strings
so that you can properly pass it as an
integer so we want to have floats then
lastly we can just show the percentage
sign so we control the log out this
entire percentage uh string we can see
in the console later on
then finally after this upload let's
just dot promise right so we can
actually just uh convert to a promise
and we can just do so This Promise will
allow us to upload uh convert this whole
upload process into a promise then we
can just do await upload dot then so uh
we can just take the data so this
callback function will be called
whenever the upload is completed
so when it's completed we're just gonna
just say
console.log
success us success
sorry success fully upload to S3
exclamation mark NSO console.lock out
the file key itself okay
then we can just do uh after that we can
just do all right then finally under
this away we can just return
promise.resolve so I want to resolve
this promise right cost is async
function right so after we have uploaded
we resolve the promise and we just want
to return two things I'm going to return
the actual file key itself and return
the file name which is file dot Nim so
make sure we turn the file key and file
name so we'll be using these two
parameters to save it to our database
later
so let's save this function okay and
let's come down here and let's create
one more utility function so this is the
last function that's going to be created
in this file so we can export function
get S3 URL so this uh functions are
taking a file key of string and
basically return us with a publicly
accessible S3 URL so that we're able to
embed the PDF within our chat screen
later
so just do cons URL equals to
uh https clones colon slash less right
put in your
um
process.env dot next underscore public
underscore S3
buckets name
right and then here we can just do dot
S3 dot AP South South
East 1 dot Amazon
aws.com slash file key
so there's actually a special formatting
for the AWS so the ews will always leave
on the bucket name dot S3 dot region so
this is where your AWS region is so it
might be different from mine and then
we'll be lift at Amazon AWS and you're
able to access it through the file key
here and then return to return this URL
so this is a utility function so that we
can actually access the fgurl just from
the file key itself and what this file
key is actually created here this at
this line here so now that we've saved
it let's actually try it out so come
back to your contact to your file upload
component right so whenever we actually
uh we just we don't want to just control
the log right we actually want to upload
to actually itself so to actually create
that function let us just get the file
so
cons file equals to accepted files index
zero okay I'm going to take the first
file and then we can just first check so
uh if file.size is bigger than 10 times
1024 times 1024 so if this is bigger
than uh 10 megabytes we don't need to
upload to S3 right this is bigger than
10 MB so let's just uh let's just show
an error so let's just alert
please upload
a smaller file then this return
okay but if it is smaller than 10 MB
then let's actually create and upload
the Amazon S3 file so let's do uh cons
data it goes to a weight upload to S3 so
we import it from our lib so because
we're using a weight let's actually also
convert it into an uh async function
okay async function
although I will upload to actually I
will pass in the file right so this file
comes from the accepted files and then
it will pass into our accept uh upload
file function that we've created in
sg.ts and then this data we can see that
it will return us with the file key and
the file name okay so this is if it
works right if it doesn't work right
let's actually put it in do a try catch
block
so if there's an a any error let's just
do console.log error okay
so away upload to actually and then that
assets do console.log uh data
so let's try it out so I'm going to save
it okay now I'll move the console here
and let's actually try uploading okay so
I'm gonna open up my console widget
sorry it's not that very responsive but
it's okay just for this video it'll be
fine so let me just uh drop a PDF here
so let me just uh so let's say we upload
this eight runtime Docs if I press on it
we can see that uploading to S3 100 so
it says that successfully updated to S3
and we get back the file key so we can
see the file key is created by having
this uploads folder and then the the
random time followed by the the actual
name of the file dot PDF right and we
get the file name also so if you come
back to our S3 so come back to your S3
bucket within AWS console right access
your chat PDF Dash YouTube uh bucket
we're able to see now that there's this
uploads folder created and we can see
the PDF that is being accessed here
right so we can see that now the the
function works and we are able to
successfully upload files onto AWS S3 so
that's excellent okay so now that we
have gotten to a decent Point within the
project now I want to explain to you
what exactly is retrieval augmented
generation and how we can actually get
the PDF to be fed into a chargeability
so that it's able to give us that uh
result such as chargeability is able to
chat with us with the context of the
documents all right so the first thing
you have to understand here is uh two
things one is what is a vector and
embeddings
okay so a vector is just an array of
numbers right a vector is just like an
arrow right so a vector is an arrow so
in this case this arrow is a
two-dimensional Vector meaning that it
has a x x coordinate and y coordinate so
here we can see that this x coordinate
is the length here and the Y container
is the height right so in this case this
Vector can be actually represented with
uh as an array of let's say two numbers
of let's see one and two also one being
the the width and 2 being the height so
in the case just for proportion this
looks more like two and one so it will
have a length of Two and a height of one
so this Vector can be represented in an
area of a two a two and one but what if
we have a vector of three dimension
right imagine you have a arrow that's
pointing out towards me I mean obviously
because we are on the screen we can
represent that but to represent the 3D
Vector we can just have three dimensions
right X Y and Z components so maybe it
can be one two and a four right so this
will be the X component the these two is
the Y component and this forms the Z
component which means how much is
pointing towards me towards the screen
right so this is what a vectors are
right so why is this vectors important
so embeddings are very similar to
vectors right so how this is going to
work is uh we have a function so this
function is able to type in a piece of
text a piece of string right so let's
say we have a string of uh I like cats
okay and let's say we take in another
string here let's say I say cats are uh
the feline species and then lastly I
have lastly I have another text that
says uh
docs are
upper seats of cats all right we can see
that all these three uh text all three
strings are kind of similar in the sense
that they're all talking about a related
to cats but how do we actually properly
Define or which attacks are more similar
to each other so this is where the
function comes in there's actually a
function within a AI that allows you to
convert this piece of text into a vector
right meaning that we have a function
let's call it um get embeddings right
this will take in a text a piece of
string and the out the input of this uh
string and it will output a list an
array of vectors so this array is going
to be like a multi-dimension uh Vector
so is a vector in the dimension of let's
say up to what thousands of Dimensions
so it's not just one two Dimensions or
even three dimensions it could be a
vector in
1536 Dimension right so the bigger the
dimension the more information it can
actually represent right so this Vector
so let's just uh take for example this I
like cats let's say that this embedding
creates a vector of uh of this of this
direction right just just for the sake
of argument right so this I like cats
right so if you embedding we get a
vector of this shape
right so the factor will actually
represent the meaning the semantic
meaning of the sentence itself right so
that's what is amazing about it so if
you take the second sentence and we
embed it so we continue into a vector
maybe this function will return us with
a vector of of this one we can see that
it's kind of similar because it's
pointing in the direction it's a similar
Direction
and then let's say if you look at these
dogs are composite of cats obviously
this is a little more different right so
actually maybe a better example would be
let's say we talk about um react is a
JS framework right so if you embed this
a string into a vector it might look
something like like this right so we can
see that the the direction of the arrow
or the vector is actually dependent on
the meaning of the actual sentence right
so how they actually create the
embedding will be using
um opening eye to create those
embeddings for us
so why is this useful useful now that we
have these vectors what we can do is
let's say now I'm trying to ask a
question so I'm going to ask a question
regarding like uh what are cats right
Uncle basically create this Vector I'm
going to create this query so this is
gonna be a query itself
I'm gonna create this query into a
vector in itself so maybe this Factor
will turn out something like this
because it's similar to the cats right
it has the semantic similarity to cats
right so it will obviously be very
similar to these two vectors then using
mathematical notations using math we can
actually find the cosine difference uh
cosine distance
right so this cosine similarity we can
see is a measure of similarity between
two non-zero vectors defined in their
product space meaning that we can
there's actually a method to find how
similar two vectors are so if we
actually basically Loop through all the
vectors and find out which one is the
most similar in this case the most
similar Vector will be this second
sentence so using pure mathematics and
vectors we're able to get uh we're able
to get this piece of text and say that
this uh text will obviously will most
likely contain the answer to my query
just by how similar they are vector
representations are
so with this uh with this factor that is
uh after we found the most similar
Vector we can actually convert this
Vector back into the text right so we'll
store this text in the metadata of this
Vector right so this Vector will contain
a few things it will contain
the embedding right it's going to be in
a array of numbers right so however
Dimension this is might be in the
thousands and it also contains a
metadata so this metadata will contain
the actual text contents right this text
content will be whatever you have here I
like cats cats let me just save it here
here so I hope that this makes a little
sense right what we're trying to do here
so we can see that each Vector contains
the embeddings itself which is the array
of numbers and it can also contain
metadata so after we have found a more
similar Vector we can extract out the
text content and then with this text
content we can actually fit the content
into a open AI so that it's able to
generate context for us
so let's see how this ties into the PDF
a function that I'm talking about
so let me just expand this so that we
have more space to explain how this
embedding works all right so imagine you
have a PDF here right so let me just
expand this a little bit bigger so that
you're able to see so let me just expand
it more okay imagine you have this PDF
it's gonna be a page so there could be
multiple pages to the PDF right so let's
just take for example we have a single
page and then maybe a paragraph multiple
paragraphs so let me just align to the
top and let's start typing so imagine we
have this one paragraph that we have
another paragraph right then lastly we
have the last paragraph that is a bit
longer
okay so within this page we have these
three paragraphs so what the vector
embedding is going to do is what our
backend is going to do is we're going to
take each page which within the document
we can just segment it into
internal documents so when we talk about
documents right now we're not talking
about PDF documents we're talking about
a segment of the PDF right so this
paragraph could be one document by
itself this uh paragraph could be
another document by itself and this PDF
or this paragraph might be another
document so we're splitting the PDF into
small chunks of documents so each chunk
will contain maybe like uh two or three
sentences one paragraph right so now
that we have segmented into a few
documents so let me just press out here
document doc dot one dot two doc three
so we're gonna take in the PDF we're
gonna segment it into a lot of documents
so each document will contain like a the
metadata so it could be the page content
itself right so this page content will
be whatever this paragraph shows right
then what we're gonna do is the second
step is to convert each document here
into a vector so remember we have a
function within open AI that allows us
to take a document uh and convert it
into a vector itself so this will then
become a vector so it's gonna be a
vector embedding
embedding so now that we have converted
all our docs so there could be maybe 20
30 documents within one PDF depends on
how we segment it
so then we have 20 uh Vector embeddings
here right then what we're going to do
with this Vector embeddings is we can
store this all these individual vectors
into a a vector database and that's
exactly where pine cone DB comes in so
pine cone DB is a vector database
exactly for a long-term memory for AI
you see right so that's what pinecon DB
is for is to store a vector embeddings
so all of this will then go inside of
pine cone
TV so that's it
so what happens now when we actually
want to search for when we type in the
chatbot how does it actually get access
to the document right so imagine now I
come back to my interface and I I search
for let's say
um what uh where did he intern at right
so imagine this is the document about my
my resume and maybe imagine this first
paragraph was talking about something
about uh I interned at relevate right a
company here right so what it's going to
do is it's gonna it's gonna vectorize
it's gonna embed this a search query
right it's going to turn it into a
vector right so this is going to turn
into another vector
embedding right then it's gonna go
through all the current it's going to go
through all the current vectors within
my Pinecone DB and you guys look for the
vector that's more similar right so in
this case the vector that's more similar
will contain the paragraph that says I
interned at Value rate because they are
similar within semantic like in terms of
the meaning
so let's say this Vector embedding the
third Vector embedding contains uh the
paragraph that says this so it contains
the original paragraph So what it's
going to do it's going to pull out this
original Vector right then it's going to
take it's going to take out the metadata
from it it's gonna extract out the
metadata then we're gonna fill in this
metadata into 10gbt so that we can
create a prompt so that we can then ask
chargeability to take in context of the
metadata and also the question and then
it can generate the answer based on
these vectors
so these are very high overview on how
we do it right so I hope you have a
better understanding of how retrieval
augmented generation actually works so
let me just break it down once again two
steps so that we can actually code it
out so the first step is actually
obviously to obtain uh the PDF right the
second step is to uh split and segment
the PDF into smaller documents right
then the third step is to take the
documents and then factorize and embed a
individual documents all right
okay so after embedding different
documents we can then store the
embeddings saw the vectors
into pine cone DB
okay then lastly whenever we want to
search so when we're trying to search
we're trying to search uh we're trying
to chat with the chatbot we're gonna
first
embed the query so turn it into a vector
then we're gonna query the pine cone DB
for similar vectors
then we're gonna extract
out the beta data of the
similar vectors
right and then finally after we extract
out metadata we can then feed a
feed metadata
meta data into uh the open AI prompt to
generate the the proper output with
contacts of the PDF so that's the uh the
minced for it so where does Lang chain
actually comes in the Lang chain will
actually help us with the splitting and
the segmenting of the PDF so I'll show
you how to actually code it up uh in the
code very very soon okay so before we
actually uh set up the pine cone and
make sure that we can embed all the
documents let's actually make sure that
we can send the file name and the file
key back to our backend whenever we
upload to S3 so underneath here I'm
going to create go to Explorer come down
to your app create a new photocop API
under here create another folder called
creates a desk chat and here we can
create a root.ts so this is a special
root.ts is a special founding within the
app router so that whenever we can see
that there's this file structure of
Slash API says create chat this will map
to the rest endpoint for this endpoint
so this will actually map to uh Slash
API slash create Dash chat then in the
front end we can hit this endpoint and
this function here will be called so
let's export a async function called
post right so we are setting a post
endpoint here so whenever they hit a
pause endpoint to this endpoint here
this code here will run okay so for now
for now we're gonna just take in the
request to be a request object and
response to be a
a response object
response okay that's good so I'm gonna
put try cash block
so if there's any error let's just
console.error error and then we'll
return the next uh next response dot
Json
error
internal server error and let's pass in
uh
status of 500. let's save it okay so for
now we're gonna accept get the body from
awaits request.json this will convert
the we want to get the request body and
for now I'm going to expect there's two
things from the body itself so we're
going to expect the file key and the
file name
okay so this Falcon the founding it's
gonna come from come from this data so
number one after we upload to S3 the
data that it returns will be two things
Falcon phone name we're gonna take these
two variables and then uh send a request
back to our backend here so that we can
actually do the pine cone pine cone
Vector embedding stuff
okay so to do the the heating of the API
I'm using react query to manage that so
I've installed and PM install at 10
stack
slash react Dash query so this react
query Library makes it very easy to
manage handle mutations and date a query
from local to server States server
endpoints basically okay so after we
have done that we need to come back to
our uh come back to our folder and let's
actually wrap our entire app in a red
query provider so come on to your
components and let's create a
provider.tsx
so we'll do tsrafc uh
tsrefc to create a snippet so this will
be a client component and I want to do
is import a few things
import a few things from
add 10 stack slash react query so we
need the uh query client provider and
also the query clients itself so we'll
initialize cons uh
query client to be a new uh sorry cons
query client equals to new query client
and then for these props we'll take in
the reaction so this is going to wrap
our entire application so we'll take in
the children to be a react.react node
then we can destructure the children
from the props itself okay then here
we're gonna basically wrap our uh query
client provider passing our client here
and then we'll just wrap the children in
this provider save it then now let's
actually wrap our layout so come back to
our layout.tsx
so inside this cloud provider okay
within this code provider let's actually
write our providers so provide
there's okay let's wrap the HTML text
okay so now that we have wrapped this
entire provider uh we can actually start
using react query so the reason why we
actually have to wrap this providers is
that uh because react query does a lot
of caching right so imagine we have one
endpoint that gives us back some data so
imagine we have this slash API says
messages data when we will hit this
endpoint it returns us with a list of
messages from the database
and then we navigate to another page and
you mix the exact same call to this
endpoint react query will be able to
detect that oh look you're making the
same same call to the endpoint but I did
have the data from a few seconds ago so
instead of making that a call back to
the backend which might waste some
resources why not I just cache the code
the data and then return you immediately
so then with this it creates a more
efficient uh workflow when you're
fetching data from the server and that's
why we need this provider such that
every component within our application
has access to the the data cache okay so
now we have this red curry let's
actually create the function to call the
backend API to actually create uh the
chat create the chat uh chat room okay
so come back to your a what's this
what's this called uh file upload
component here file upload here so above
these use Drop Zone let's actually
create a mutation so mutation is just a
function that allows you to hit the
backend API so cons mutates so actually
just uh cons let's destructure from use
mutate mutation from react query right
we can see that it actually returns us
with a few things returns us with a lot
of things like is loading loading State
uh error State even the mutate so this
function will be called so for this use
mutation we'll pass in a few things
we'll pass in the query key
it's like not quirky uh not query key
it's just a directly mutation function
so this mutation function will be an
async function right so let's actually
install axios because we need access to
actually make that API call to the
backend so npm install axios
so do cons response equals to awaits
axios
so import actuals
uh import access from axials
actions.post we're going to hit the
slash API slash create chat right so
this create chat will hit this endpoint
here
and then we're going to pass in two
things I'm going to pass in the file key
and the file name from the body right so
how do we get this we can get it by
destructuring here from
South key and file
name so this will be the structured from
here file key which is a string
and file name which is also a string
save this so later on we'll pass this
we'll pass this Falcon file name into
this mutate function which will be we
can access it here so then we'll pass in
file key and file name
okay awesome
then after we've made that call we can
just return response dot data okay so
how do we actually call this mutate
function right so this muted we can just
come down here so after we have uploaded
to SG right we got this data we get a
check
if not data dot file key or not data dot
file name so if for some reason there's
no file key and file name we know that
something has went wrong so let's
actually alert something went wrong and
return
if not we can actually call the mutate
function so you see this mutate function
comes from this top here right and then
we Define this mutation function within
the the property
this will take in two things Falcon and
file name and right now if I then uh if
I come down to mutate right and I pass
in the object we can see that we need
this Falcon file name so we can just
pass in this data because this data is
ensured to have the fault key and found
it so we can see that it matches the the
data type here matters whatever we
expect from this mutation function
till then this data this data this data
Falcon phoneme will be passed up to our
backend endpoint
okay so then for the mutate the second
object will contain a few things a few
callbacks for on success so it gives us
this on success so if there is if it's
successful right we'll get back the data
from the backend endpoint so let's
consult the log data in case there's any
error let's just take the error let's
just uh console.log error so let me just
add one more toast uh toasting so I'm
gonna add this Library called react hot
toast so it's just for nice alerts right
so if you come back into this Library we
can see that we can have this nice tools
alert to notify whenever something is
happening right
so let's install that Library so come
down here and do npm install react Dash
hot
Dash toast
okay so to use these react hotels we
need to come down back to our layout.tsx
import we need to import uh this toaster
from react that's hot toast what do we
need to import we need to import the
toaster component then underneath the
HTML let's just import the toaster here
so this one is actually I used to
actually create the alerts so save it
come down here so we will just replace
all these alerts with a toast so we can
see that this toast we can import from
react Hot Tools right toes dot error
file too large okay so let's save it
okay so come out come back to your to
your layout so this toaster should be
within this HTML tag so make sure it's
within the HTML tag so now let's save
this and then let's refresh the page and
hopefully I'll think it's back okay
that's good
so we can do toaster error so this will
create that nice pop-up notification
right then we do have this alert then
for this alert here we can also do a
tools dot error
uh something went wrong
return this and lastly here we can just
toast. error uh
uh can uh error
creating
chat okay so let's save this and now
everything looks perfect
so basically what will happen is
whenever we drop the file it's going to
upload to S3 right so so whenever we
upload a file it's going to call this
upload to actually a function right you
return us with the file key and the file
name demo basically call this mutate
passing in the 4K and file name this
mutate will then uh take the following
phone name and pass it back to our
endpoint create chat so by right right
now if you send the upload a file you'll
come it will then uh will be able to
console.log out the
funky and the file name so let me save
this and let's actually try it out so
this will obviously be locked out in the
server because it is running on the back
end so it will work on the terminal so
let's try out so I'm going to press job
PDF and let me just upload uh upload
this uh eight runtime docs so if I press
this but right here we can see that the
create chat is being run and then
hopefully it's able to tell us that okay
so now right now there's error okay so
obviously uh we didn't return anything
from this that's what therefore
stringing error but right now we can see
that it's working we can see that this
file key and the file name is being
logged up so this is the file key and
this is the file name and it's being
logged out within the backend so we know
that this is working
so one more thing here for the file
upload right so other than the mutate
function remember it also give us that
it's loading it's loading state right
for this is loading State we can
actually use that to display a loading
component while it's uploading so I'm
gonna just uh come down to our file up
right here I'm gonna Define one more
state I'm gonna call it uploading then
set uploading
so it's gonna be a new state react or
use state
so by default it's going to be false
then whenever we actually upload a file
here whenever we upload a file on drop
we're gonna first do
we gotta first do set uploading to be
true
then underneath here finally so after
whether yes whether it's filled or
whether it's succeeded we will set
uploading to false okay so then we have
these two variables right because this
is loading and uploading so if any of
these are true let's display a loading a
loading prop loading screen
so if you come down here for this input
right below the input right now we are
still showing this uh this drop PDF no
matter whether it's loading or not so to
create a better experience let's do
if it's a low uploading
or is loading
is loading
okay
so this uploading uh of this uploading
variable will be true when I'm uploading
to S3 and this is loading variable be
true whenever I'm sending the talking
headphone name back to my backend
so if if any of these are true I'm gonna
show a loading State okay I'm not sure a
loading state
right but if any of these are if both of
these are false then it's fine if I show
the drop PDF box here so I move this up
sorry can move this up here then for
this here I'm gonna show a react
fragment okay so here I can just
actually show my loading State okay for
the loading State let me just show a
sorry let me just show a loader 2 from
Lucid react
so let me give a class name of height of
10 width of 10. and we'll do text blue
or 500 and then finally
animate spin
below the Loader 2 let me show a p-tech
this is a spilling T2 gbt Dot
will give you a costume of margin top of
two text SM
text slits of 400 and let's save it so
let's try out right now so this root.ts
uh if this is successfully I'm gonna do
a return
nextresponse.json
message uh message off
success
so let's save this
and let's see if it works okay
so if it works here instead of console
logging the data I'm gonna do
toast.success I'm gonna do data Dot
message
so let me just save it and let's try out
so I'm going to press drop PDF another
drop uh drop the same PDF here and see
it's loading then after it's loading is
sent to the backend
if it sends to the back end we can see
that a success message pops up so
everything is perfect everything is
working well so now we can actually
start working on uh converting the PDF
into vector embeddings and storing
within time code
all right so let's actually now create
the pine cone feature so come back to
your root.ts on the create chat feature
So eventually with this Falcon and
founding we want to execute the we want
to execute the steps right so obtain the
PDF
split and segment the PDF factorize and
store the vectors into Pinecone DB so
first thing here is essentially create a
account for Pinecone so come down to
Pine Cone DB then just go to that
pinecon db.io so you can either log in
or just sign up for free so in this case
every account so I'm gonna log in okay
so uh once you log into the uh
app.pinecone.io the dashboard right come
down to create index so we will first
create a index so index within Pinecone
is just like uh one uh it's a database
within like a normal SQL database so
it's a place to store all your different
vectors right so let me explain this uh
the terminology within Pinecone so pine
cone terms okay
so we have index and index is just a
database to store all your different
vectors right then within index uh
within Pinecone there's nothing called
name space so namespace is like a a
table so imagine we'll have a different
namespace for each PDF so uh it's to
segment uh PDF Vector spaces so
basically each PDF will have its own
namespace and then each namespace will
contain its own vectors then basically
we can query whenever we query we can
pass in a namespace parameter so that it
will only query vectors of query for
similar vectors within that specific
name space yeah so that's how it's going
to work so come to the name so give it
anything you want I'm gonna quite uh
chat PDF Dash YouTube
then for this index for the dimensions
put one five three six so it can have up
to 15 uh 1500 Dimensions right for the
magic living in cosine so we're using
cosine similarity for the algorithm
comparison right so you can then see
this distance metric to use for
measuring similarity between the vectors
they're just two starter and then leave
everything as default so it's a free
tier index just press create index so in
this case I already have an index right
and because I'm on the free tier it only
allows me to have one index but it's
okay you just create an index and you
can you're still able to follow along so
after you have created the index uh you
should be able to come in and you're
able to see different uh information
about it so in this case you can see
that right now at 578 factors within my
database right so in later on when we
start inserting it will increase also so
now I need to do is come down to your
API key section okay so just create a
new come out here and create a new API
key and name it whatever you want just
name it I'm gonna name it chat PDF
YouTube
so create a key
so as it's waiting we will need two
things from it we need a Pinecone
environment and also need a pine cone
API key
okay so after you created the key in
this has a limit uh YouTube we need two
things we need the environment we also
need the API key itself so we need these
two things so come down to your dot EnV
right we're going to create a new
section just for the pine cone
pine cone okay so we need the uh pine
cone environment so copy in the
environment here is the location of
where it's located
we also need a pine cone uh API key
API key so let me copy in this here copy
and paste it here
so let's save it and then we can just
quit out of this playing console for now
okay
so come down to your directory let's go
under your lip folder and let's actually
create a pine cone.ts so store all
functions for pine cone Pine cone.ts
okay
so the first thing here I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna declare a lead pine cone to be
a uh actually let's install the pine
phone first right so let's install npm
install uh add pine cone data based
success pine cone
so let's install that so we'll be
installing a few things also
um
okay one more thing we need to install
is uh actually let's install it as as we
go along as we need it so let's import
the pine cone first pine cone
cone
from
at Pine Cone database says pine cone
right this pine cone uh so here uh
pine cone client right so this pine cone
variable here will start uh will be a
type of pine cone client or no
so initi has to do now so this could be
a global variable here
after this we're gonna do uh we can
export a
con function uh conscat Prime cone
client
equals to a async function right so this
can help us initialize the pine cones so
if not pine cone so if you have not
already set the variable what we're
gonna do is we're gonna call Pine Cone
it goes to New pine cone clients right
then we'll do a weight pine cone dot
init so in it we need to initialize it
with our API keys right so for the
environment we do a process.env DOT pine
cone and vironment so it's what you have
copy in from the EnV here okay so make
sure it exists and then we also need the
API key so this will be process
.env dot pine cone API key make sure it
also exists so put the exclamation mark
to ensure that typescript that it will
always exist
then in the end we just want to
return the time code
Pine code
excellent okay that's good
so now let's actually create the
function to load S3 into pine cone right
so right now we can see that we have a
few things that we need to do let me
find the proper stuff here uh so we got
a few steps right we need to obtain the
PDF split and segment vectorize and
store it so we have four steps here so
let's see how we can map it into a
function
function called load S3 into pine cone
so this thing is going to take in a file
key it's going to take in a file key
which is a string so this file key will
be what is being passed from to the from
this root so let's actually call this
function right here already so let's
just do let's save this file and let's
call await load S3 into Pinecone and
let's pass in the file key
okay so what this function is actually
going to be the bulk of this project
right so I'm gonna go through it line by
line and let's see how it works so the
first step is
number one is obtain the PDF so how to
actually download the how do we actually
download the uh the S3 file key into our
local directory so that we can read the
text from the PDF right so within this
opt-in PDF we actually need to uh
download
and read from PDF okay so to do that
let's actually create a let's create a
S3 function for this come down to your
uh directory right under our lip right
instead of this actually.ts let's create
another function called S3
server.ts right so this will make sure
that this file will only run on the
server
okay so come down to your F3 server.ts
let's create a function export async
function
download
from
from S3
okay so this download from actually will
obviously take the file key and then
download uh download the the SG file
onto our local local computer
so it's getting in the file key which is
gonna be a string okay
so what do you want to do we're going to
first import the import the AWS
from AWS SDK so it's very similar to
what we did just now so we'll do a try
catch block so if there's any error
let's just console.error error just
return
now okay so we're gonna do uh AWS dot
config right dot update so it's the same
thing just now access key ID copy
process.env
dot next underscore public S3 access key
ID make sure you exist
there was only the secret access
key right will be the same thing here so
after configure the AWS object right so
actually we can just copy from Azure
right we don't want you to type this out
single copy up here copy this so we're
just trying to initialize the S3 bucket
here okay
now that we have that let us do cons
params
uh equals to the we need the
um What's this called we need the bucket
to be
process.env dot next public
S3 bucket name and then for the key for
the key we need a file key
right so with these programs we can
actually obtain the S3 from that so we
do console object equals to us rate as
three dots uh gets object
passing the programs so these params
because it contains the file key is able
to abstract out the unique ID unique uh
file from uh S3
so we'll convert it to a promise right
so we await the promise so this object
now contains the uh the actual file
object then all we need to do is uh
let's let's import the import FS for
file system from FS so mean this app has
to actually download the file to our
system
so we just need to do
um
uh fs.writes file sync right one give me
a file name file name and we'll just do
object dot body as buffer okay so let's
define this file name so this file name
is where do we want to install in our
local how do we want to in download it
to a local folder right so we'll just
download it to slash temp slash PDF uh
uh Dash let's actually create this into
a template string
uh dates dot now
dot PDF so it's just going to download
it about 10 directory a temporary folder
with a unique PDF with a date dot now
and just name it PDF so then we'll just
download it into our file system okay
then I want to return the file name
so that's that's all we need to do so
this function will actually take in a
file key and just download it to our
folder and return the file name to where
the folder is located where the file is
actually downloaded tool so let's save
this and let's come back to our
pinecone.ts so with this function with
the SG function we can actually use that
right so let's just do console.log uh
downloading
S3 into file system
so we can call a cons file name equals
to awaits download from S3 passing the
file key so this is from the S3 server
that we are importing right
okay then the second step is to actually
uh get the get the PDF so how do we
actually get the text from the PDF so
because the PDF is a DOT PDF right how
do you get text all the text format from
the PDF itself right so what we can do
is um let me just
we need to install one other thing we
need to install a let me see I think we
need to install link chain so the link
chain provides us with a nice uh PDF
loader such that we go to convert PDF
into text strings so let's mpm install
length chain itself so launching create
gives us a lot of utilities to actually
do a lot of AI uh and machine learning
utility functions
so what we need from a lang chain from
we need from length chain slash document
underscore loaders
loaders slash uh FS PDF so this will
give us a PDF loader class right so from
this from file system PDF so this PDF
loader will be able to read from the
file system and give us a text of that a
PDF file so we can just use this so
we'll do cons loader equals to new PDF
loader
right and we pass in the file name that
we got back after we've downloaded it
here right so if something goes wrong so
if not found him so maybe that there's
some error downloading here so if
there's no file name let's just throw a
new error saying that we could not
download from S3 so that by the time we
get to this line we're guaranteed that
there is a file name here okay so what
I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna stop here
for now and I'm gonna just uh
console.log
uh
let me see I'm gonna get coins Pages it
goes to loader.load so we can call uh to
get the pages we can do loader.load so
this loaded the load will then look at
this it will read the buffer content and
metadata based on the type and call the
parts so basically what this does is it
return us with all the pages within the
PDF right so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna just return the pages so we're
gonna we're gonna see what have what
what happens when we load this in so I'm
gonna save it I'm Gonna Save this file
first and then come back to our root
right remember that we are we call this
load actually into Pine code so right
now well it return it will return us
with uh with uh with a bunch of pages
right so we can see these pages is a
type of document so there's a lot of
documents right so let me just await
this loader.load okay so then finally
here we can see that it's going to be an
array of documents right so this is
exactly what I mean by a splitting and
segmenting the PDF
so let me save it come back to our root
and let's just return uh the conspages
equals to
let's just cancel the log of the pages
so let's see actually what what we
actually get back here okay so I'm gonna
come back to my uh come back to my uh
file upload so instead of just
a toast of success Also let's do code
so.org data so just delete this
okay so now hopefully if we if we did
everything correctly we're able to see
the documents being loaded from the
backend
so clear your output here
okay then uh let's press drop PDF right
so I'm gonna drop the H1 time docs right
so right now you can see that it's
uploaded S3 and then it's gonna hit the
back end the backend is going to load
the PDF into a file system and then read
okay so this is normal to be expected
right so we actually need one more
library for the PDF parts right so these
internal dependency of the blank chain
PDF loader right we need this pidf parse
uh Library so that LinkedIn is able to
properly pass the PDF for us
so let's refresh it and let's actually
try again all right let me just refresh
the page hopefully everything is okay so
there's uh one more of this very common
error that I actually faced while
developing this app is you see this
weird stuff here and eventually it will
say let me look for the error okay reach
hit limit allocation field right
JavaScript keep out of memory so what I
did was I I copied this and I searched
up stack Overflow so about this error is
about my node.js running out of memory
trying to run this application
right we can see that uh this type
overflow solution is trying to say that
um
a JavaScript hit runoff memory so what
to do is actually we want to allow
node.js to actually use more memory than
what is allows by default so what you
want to do is come down to your
package.json right so whenever you
whenever you do npm run Dev next Dev
right we can actually set one more thing
up here we can do okay so we do uh so
here next step we do export uh node
underscore options right so we want to
pass in uh a variable so we can do
here so what options we want we do
um next o space the size equals to
8192 right so we're gonna basically
export a variable EnV variable called a
Max o space size to be eight uh eight
gigabytes of RAM so we allow it to use
eight gigs of space size and then after
that we can run the normal Next Step so
this um ampersine Ampersand sign allows
you to run two commands in in one one
npm script okay so I think for Windows
if you're using any windows I think
instead of export it should be set right
so I think you have to play around to
see how you set your environment
variables based on your operating system
so for Windows I think it's set but for
Mac OS and Linux we're going to use
export
so let's save this and let's press npm
run Dev again and this time you can see
that it's exporting this function is
exporting this configuration for node.js
to use more a memory before running the
actual Dev server so after we have
solved that issue let's actually now try
running the server again so I'm going to
refresh the page and hopefully now it
will work this time okay so I'm going to
collapse for this a little boom bit more
so it's going to compile the page so
let's wait for you to compile
okay
so now let's actually drop a PDF here
I'm going to do upload this I'm going to
open up my console so you can see that
it is uploaded to S3 and hopefully now
it's going to hit our backend it's going
to download the F3 file into our system
then it's going to use LINE chain to
read the PDF into text and you return us
with a list of documents so let's wait a
way for that to actually work uh and
okay now it works perfectly so we can
see that it's returned from the back end
so we consult the data so this data
comes from this uh Pages here load
actually into Pinecone so let's inspect
it so within this we can see that uh
these pages is an array of 13 objects So
within this object you can see that
there's a page content and this is
exactly what we are looking for this is
the text representation of the PDF right
so each object here will have page
content and also the metadata right so
the page content is the actual stuff but
here the metadata is always interesting
the metadata will give us the location
so which document uh uh is so that's one
page so for now the default function
will basically
segment the PDF into single singular
pages so you have 13 Pages therefore it
segments into 13 uh objects within the
array so each page will have its own
page content and its own page number so
if you come down to the second object
here we can see that the page content is
the second page and the better data will
say that it's page number is two okay so
that's perfect so with that now we can
continue working on the Pinecone feature
okay so I just want to make sure that it
runs on the same page as what we're
actually doing so now that we understand
that this function these Pages variable
is going to be a record of
uh page content and also the
metadata right so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to Define my own
custom type so above here outside of the
function I'm gonna do uh export a type
of PDF page right so this PDF page
remember just now we saw in the console
it has a page content right which is a
string and also it has metadata within
the metadata I have the location which
is which contains a page number which is
a number so this is uh this is what I
got just by looking into the console and
looking at what this console.locks out
okay so now that we have that let's
actually just do
let's wrap this here and just do s PDF
page
here so then we have properly type it so
right now we can see these Pages it's
now properly a PDF page so it has the
type annotations
Okay so it's perfect so now let's
actually move on uh to the next few
steps so okay so now we actually need to
split and segment the PDF right so right
now how it does the splitting is that it
splits the PDF by pages so if the PDS
have 13 Pages it's going to split it
into 13 pages but the thing is that's
not very efficient on not very ideal for
vectorizing because we want the vector
each Vector to contain only a very small
paragraph So maybe two to three
sentences uh so we don't want the each
Vector to contain the whole page content
that's not very good for vectorization
so what we're going to do is we're gonna
use another function from I think it's
from uh Pinecone so pinecon gives us a
function called recursive character text
splitter so it helps us with the text
splitting into a smaller paragraph
so we could be doing that right now so
let me just close this terminal and
let's continue working on the function
so now we are talking about the Second
Step so now we have these pages right we
can move on to the second step
number two which is split uh
splits n uh segment the PDF
into documents into smaller documents so
right now these pages is an array of
documents but the documents are still
too big So within the 13 objects within
the array we want to split it even
further
so what we're gonna do is I'm going to
write a function
I'm going to write a function just
called uh uh export a function is called
called async function we could call it
prepare document
all right this is going to take in a
page of PDF page
and then it's going to take in a
splitter
sorry a splitter
sorry so it's not taking a PDF page just
a PDF page and what this function does
is it takes in a singular page so
remember just now a page is uh one of
the objects within the array of 13 pages
right so we're gonna look look at the
page content and then split it up even
further so to get the splitter to how to
actually split it we need to install uh
uh we need to install a mock package
from Pinecone database itself so npm
install
at Pine Cone that's database
slash uh doc splitter so this is another
package within pangon database that
gives some utility function to help
speak out documents so let's import that
function first so import a
import fittings from at Pinecone
database such as doc splitter so we need
two things mini we need the document
type uh the document class and also a
recursive character tag splitter okay so
uh let's come down our prepared document
so let's actually do the splitting here
so the first thing here we need to do is
we can uh export a few things from
uh the page itself so remember this page
we Define this PDF page our custom type
here so we can destructure the page
content and also the metadata okay then
we want to do is Page content we want to
just replace uh page contents dot
replace uh
uh replace
uh
let's do a rejects for the
says sorry how do we actually do the
right checks he'll be slash n slash g so
just replace it with a empty string so
this is just a regex to replace all the
new line characters with a empty string
then finally we split the docs so we do
uh corn stocks equals to a weight uh so
how do you get the splitter we can do
corn splitter
equals to new recursive character text
beta then we'll do splitter Dot
uh
speech documents so when the speed the
documents so these documents is going to
be an array right but in this case we
only have one PDF page so inside here is
only gonna have uh one document so each
document is like one page within this
function
so we'll pass in a new document so this
new document is defined from the from
what we've just imported here
right so this document will contain a
few things so the page content will be
the same right so this page content
comes from the PDF page here however the
metadata we can actually specify uh our
custom metadata so we can pass in a page
number to be the metadata DOT
location.page number and also let's pass
in the text so this text will actually
contain uh the original text of it so
let's uh so because this document will
be vectorized and stored in Pine Cone
this text might be too long for Vector
for pine cone to handle so let's create
another function uh let's create another
function for this so
export cons truncate string by byte
so this gonna take in
a string I also taking a number of bytes
so what we want to do is just cons
encoder
uh sorry this will be a arrow function
const encoder equals to new text
encoding Act 10 new text encoder and we
just want to do return new text encoder
uh sorry text and text decoder I mean
text decoder right text decoder pass in
the utf-8 so we'll just give you a utf-8
and then decode it
encoding of the string right
and then after the encoding when the
size slice
from 0 to bytes
so this will make sure that the string
that we're passing is within the byte
within the size the proper size so I'm I
think uh Pinecone only accepts uh
strings uh the metameter data takes to
be up to uh 36 000 uh bytes therefore we
pass in the 36 000 to make sure that it
truncates off properly so that it
doesn't cause any errors when we
actually insert into pine cone
okay the last thing we have actually
after we have uh split up so this
splitter will take in the original
document and you'll split up into
smaller documents then we can just
return the docs so now these docs uh
what it does is it takes in one single
page and splits up into multiple dogs so
it can be spiritual into five six
paragraph for a single page all right so
now let's actually call this prepare
document okay so for this before we
don't return the page what we're
actually going to do is we do cons uh
documents equals to a weight
promise.org right want to pass in Pages
dot map so for each page we just want to
uh
for each page we actually want to call
the prepare document on the page itself
right so this can actually be
short-handed into just prepare document
so what this does is
so once you have loaded in all the 13
pages from the PDF document we can call
the prepare document a function on the
single page so then it's gonna split it
up into it's even smaller chunks so
maybe so maybe like let's say Pages was
in a array of 13 elements array of 13
Pages after calling these prepared
documents on this array of 13 Pages
these documents could be like maybe a
real of like even 100 so it takes in the
single page and speeds up even further
so now that we have all these uh
documents right we can then vectorize
and embed the individual documents right
so that's the third step now so we're
doing well so I hope that you are still
falling on so now we actually want to
factorize and embed in the visual
documents okay
so let me just create another function
here uh cop embed document so async
function embed document okay so uh
actually before that let's just comment
this out first let's actually use the
open AI function to actually uh get the
embeddings of a single string right so
come down to our uh let me see where did
I put it okay come down to your file
structure come down to your lip let's
create a new file called embeddings dot
yes
okay so for this embeddings.ts uh we
need to install the open AI package
right so npm install
open AI Dash H so this open AI H is a
alternative package to the normal open
AI package that's Edge compatible so
this package allows us to run this uh
Pinecone thing on the edge
so after we have done that let us import
a few things from
open AI h
so we need the open AI API and also the
configuration object
so the first thing here we need to do is
config equals to new configuration
pass in the API key so how do you get
the open year API key so let's come down
to our browser
so just come down to open AI API
okay come down to the API and then look
for the API key so I'm going to just
zoom out a little so that it doesn't
uh okay so come to the menu and search
for the API and just go to our uh
overview
so get started for Developers
okay so you see this GPT allows us to
generate embeddings that can be used for
tasks like text color classification so
we want the embeddings API so just log
into the account right and then you can
actually read more about embeddings uh
within the docs here so come down to
your view API Keys okay so for this
create a new secret key within the API
just name it whatever you want I'm gonna
name it chat PDF uh that's YouTube
create a secret key and then I need to
copy in this secret key and let's close
this tab
so come back to your dot EnV file
so let's just put a open AI API sorry
open AI yeah API key just paste it in
here save it let's close it so now we
have this open AI API key in our
configuration
okay then let's just do cons open AI
equals to a new open AI API pass in the
config object
so now let's actually export the async
function called get embeddings
just gonna take in the text of a text
with a string so this function purely
converts a text into a vector right so
let's do a try catch block
right so if there's an area let's just
do control the lock error calling open
AI embedding
API
passing the error
okay
didn't actually just throw
the sorry true
throw the error okay so let's just do
the contrast points
equals to a weight
open AI dot create embedding
right so passing in the model so for the
model we actually want to choose the
text Dash embedding uh embedding
sorry make sure you're spelling it
correctly embedding that's Ada Dash zero
two so this is the model that actually
helps us do the embeddings
so it's fast and also efficient and also
uh capable enough therefore passing the
input right just do input sorry the
input will be text Dot replace so just
replace all the new line characters with
an empty string here
empty spacer
then lastly return uh
we want to do a cons result equals to a
weight response dot Json
and we can just do return results dot
data index 0 dot embedding
s number so it's gonna be a vector so
this embedding is merely a vector of
multi-dimensional uh numbers so this is
just a vector itself so let's close this
embedding file then we can actually use
it in our pinecone.ts
so we want to basically remember when to
embed the documents right embed the
individual documents so uh for the embed
documents let's take in the doc as a
document type so this is from the pine
cone pine cone type annotation
so uh this is going to let's just do try
catch put in a try catch block
so if there's an error let's just do
control Dot Lock
error embedding documents
and passing the error
then we'll just throw
the error okay so what I'm going to do
so first we're going to do we'll get
embedding embeddings equals to a weight
gets embeddings we import it from the
embeddings file that we just did just
now so doc Dot Page content so we're
going to basically convert the page
content into the vector
get hash of the page content so for the
hashing function rule npm install
uh md5 so this has helpless ID make sure
that we can ID the uh we can ID the
embedding ID the vector within pine cone
right so let me just import import md5
from md5
all right so I think we need to install
the types for this so npm install at
types for md5
okay so let's save the file come down
here so for the hash for the unit ID
we'll just do md5 pass in the dock.page
contact
then lastly return the return oh sorry
we want to return a vector right so this
is going to return a vector so the
vector uh type so how do we get the
vector type the vector type actually
comes from uh the Pinecone database so
you see this at pinecon Dash database
right we can actually import the vector
type okay so come down here so this is
going to return this as a vector
so then here
we can actually do that we can get the
type annotation
so we need the ID so this ID is going to
be the hash we need the values uh the
the values to be the embedding
embeddings
so these extra the weddings within the
factor and then we can pass in the
metadata for all the vector that is
going to be stored within Pinecone
so we can store the text will be Doc dot
metadata dot text Dot text right and
then um for the page number we can pay
the page number we can do dot dot
metadata Dot Page number
so this doctor method data.txt actually
comes from here remember we we put the
beta data here we put in page number and
text so now what we're doing here is we
are accessing it here so the
metadata.txt uh here metadata.txt here
okay so I hope hope everything's still
clear
so then we just return the vector okay
so right now we can see that now
basically this takes in a document and
returns a promise of a vector
so now let's actually vectorize and
embed the individual documents so we do
the same uh very similar to just now we
just do con vectors equals to awaits
promise to all
we do document uh we do uh documents dot
fat so we flatten the document first
then map to it and then for each
document we call the embed document on
that function so then this will then
give us back a array of vectors right so
if you come back to our xcality draw we
can see that we are now on this step we
have already broken down into each
document a small document then we have
created into Vector embeddings so then
now the last step is just to put these
Vector embeddings up to Pine Cone DB
okay so we're doing really good we're
doing excellent so now we have the last
step so the first step here is uh upload
to Pinecone okay so let's just get the
client first so cons client equals to
await get pine cone Clan right so this
pinecon is what we have written up just
now here so it just returns us to the
pine cone with the initial the config
the API key configs so to get the pine
cone Index right so this index is the
name of the database right so we want to
do a weight uh client dot index so what
is the name of the Pinecone index so for
me I'm just now I name it uh chat PDF
right so if you come back to your
uh pine cone app dot sorry app Dot
pine cone
dot IO
right so for me I name it chat PDF so
the pipe the index name has a WeChat PDF
okay
so that's good so after we have gotten
the pine cone index we can then let's
just say uh
Let's do
console.log let's just put a debug log
that says uh
inserting vectors into Pine code okay
and then we can just do
get the namespace called name space so
remember we have a different name space
for each document we can get the file
key right so this toky is being passed
up okay so there's a bug that I faced
just now where uh if the foggy was not
in all ASCII characters right then
obviously it's just gonna be through an
error within Pinecone so we need we need
to write another function that actually
converts uh the file key into s key
characters so come down to your folder
come down to your uh utils your utils or
TS
and then let us create a function called
convert to ASCII so export function
converts to F key okay he's gonna take
in the input string of type string
all we're going to do is remove any non
ASCII
characters
so this is all the function does so we
do cons as ski uh string equals to input
dot input single replace and put these
projects in so I just got this from
um chat GPT honestly yeah so you can
just you can just copy whatever I have
here uh we can just copy what I have
here within the code base so let me just
actually copy my own version within my
code base so to make sure that
everything is correct okay so make sure
you are putting in this project so this
I think it just takes any non-sk
characters and just replace it with an
empty string so then lastly we just want
to return the SQ string so let's save it
we can close it off
so remember for the file key
uh we want to take the we want to uh
convert
two
as key right one to
import the function
from YouTube right so we're passing this
file key so to make sure that the name
space is ASCII compatible
then lastly what we can just do is we
can just call uh so one more thing we
want to import from pinecon database is
the utils function right so we'll name
it you rename the utils as pine cone
utils right so this is a renaming of the
the utils function that's exported
So within this utils uh pine cone
utils there's a function called
upset so it will just help us update and
push the vectors into the pine cone
index so we're passing the pine code
index first
then we're passing the vectors they're
going to insert into pine cone passing
the namespace which is this a convert
ASCII and lastly you can see the last
function here is the chunk size uh the
chunk size so I'm going to just enter a
10 so I experiment around and just found
10 was a nice number to use for this
then let's just just return uh the
documents index zero so we'll just
return the first document right just for
the sake of it so these are this is the
bulk of the the this whole retriever
augmented generation so if you're able
to understand the concept and able to
implement it like here then we are
actually really good to go
so let me just save the file so if you
come back to our uh
root dot TS right remember that we call
this load actually into Pinecone so we
got this let me just recap everything
right we call the phone key we
downloaded S3 into the file system then
we loaded it and then we split into the
individual uh we split and segment the
PDF into smaller documents we vectorize
and embed the documents then we finally
uploaded to Pinecone
okay
so uh now that we have that all set up
for us uh
we can just call this so we we are not
actually getting anything back any
useful information back right so we just
need to await uh load S3 into uh the the
pine cone and now here is actually where
we create a new chat so we want to
remember uh create a new chat within our
database right so actually let us do
that so to use Json orm to create the
chat let's do cons uh sorry let us do
await
um sorry oh it's DB so this DB is from
our ad lib slash DB right so we do
insert
so we want to insert uh into the chats
so we can import these chats from our DB
schema
so uh insight into chats we want to
insert when to insert the values
of we can see there's some type
annotations right so all these type
annotations comes from
the schema here that we have defined so
that's a very useful feature for orms so
we're passing the uh uh sorry we'll pass
in the file key to be the file key
itself will pass in the PDF name to be
the file.name file name then we'll pass
in a PDF URL right so remember we wrote
a function within our S3 that helps us
get back the sorry
this actually we wrote a function that
helps us get back the S3 URL from the
file key so we can actually use that so
get S3 URL passing in the file key and
lastly we need the user ID
so how do we get the user ID so uh
um what's that called clerk actually
also provides us with another with the
auth function right remember we use the
auth function just now so we can do uh a
weight loss from clerk says next shares
right so this will return us back with
the current user ID
so uh just in case here just in case
user ID doesn't exist so if not user ID
that means they are not authenticated we
just return a next response dot Json
saying that the error is unauthorized
and passing a status of for one so now
everything works fine everything works
perfectly right we can see that we're
able to get the user ID from clerk to
protect our API we're also able to get
uh insert into our database
so if you want to return well we want to
return the inserted chat ID so we can do
returning returning right we pass in the
uh once we turn the inserted ID
you'll be church.id
so uh with here we can actually
destructure the chords uh chat ID equals
to this
okay
so this chat ID or then uh will we will
get will give us by this inserted ID so
we can just return finally we can just
return next response dot Json
right we're going to pass in the chat ID
to be chat uh ID index 0 dot inserted ID
right because how it works is that this
DB dot insert the values right this
returns an array of all the inserted
values but in this case we only inserted
one value therefore we want the index
into zero and then we want to get this
inserted ID which is what we return from
here so this is how we actually get the
chat ID from drizzle RM
then we can just pass in the status of
200. to make sure that uh to tell the
finance that okay everything is going
fine
okay so I think everything looks perfect
everything looks perfect and then so we
have created this create chat root so
now finally let's go back to our file
upload and finish up the function uh to
actually create and upload the Pinecone
vectors
okay so if you come back to our file
upload uh file here so remember this
data this data will now contain this uh
chat ID so let's just uh destructure
this chat ID from this on success so if
it successfully returns if the function
runs successfully then we'll ensure that
there's a chat ID here right so if
there's a chat ID what do you want to do
we'll return this we're going to uh
redirect them to the chat page to that
particular chat ID that has been created
so I'm going to do tools of success
first I'm gonna see that okay chat has
been created and then I'm gonna push
them there push them uh push the router
to the chat page so take a console
router equals to use router so import
this from not Nexus router right it's
not Nexus router it should be imported
from next slash navigation
right so make sure you're importing use
router from next navigation and not from
uh next slash router
so after we have this router we can come
down here on success we just do
router.push
ID okay then everything is perfect let's
just control dot error if there's any
errors
and let's save it and I think that's it
for this page and then I think we are
we're good to go so I think everything
will work now so let's actually test
here and make sure that everything is
working
so I'm gonna open up my console so I'm
gonna monitor what was happening here
so I'm gonna actually come back to my
paint code my app.pinecone app dot Pine
cone.io
uh do I have it here
so I'm gonna go into my chat PDF a pine
code index so right now we can see that
I have 578 sorry like 570 vectors so if
everything goes well and I upload a new
file the vector counts will increase
because I'm pushing new vectors into the
database right so I'm gonna come down to
my chat PDF YouTube I'm gonna go to I'm
gonna drop my PDF here and let's pray to
God that it works so I'm gonna upload my
age runtime for cell docs it's gonna be
splitting the T so right now we can see
that it's hitting the create chat
endpoint so let's look at the control
log so make sure that everything is is
working fine so let's hope that it works
so now you can see that it says
inserting vectors into a pine cone right
so you saw just now
uh inserting vectors into pine cone so
now everything is working perfectly
right so if I come back here
I should see that it has now increased
to 591 so that means it works it works
perfectly and we have created the chat
and has been pushed into the database so
that works perfectly everything is going
really smoothly so in the next part
we'll be creating the chat page all
right so now that we've completed the
pine cone uploading let's actually work
on the chat pages so I think from here
onwards it's going to be much easier so
if you're able to understand the first
part here I think from now on would be
um much more fun
okay so to create a chat page come down
to your app right come down to your app
uh and we'll be creating a
a new photocop chat right and this chat
will have a wall cut that says chat ID
and within this chat you have a page dot
thtsx so this is a special wild card
reading app router so that this maps to
like slash chat slash uh whatever here
so we'll put the X
get this ID from the URL so we'll do TSI
fce right so that we can get the can we
get the arrow function let's do it chat
page
okay I'm Gonna Save this file
then I'm gonna close the sidebar
okay so now let me refresh the page and
right now we'll be showing the chat
picture okay that's perfect so how do we
actually get the ID to chat ID from the
the params so we need the props right uh
uh next is actually provides us with the
params within the props so we'll get the
programs object and then within it we
have a chat ID
which is a string so this chat ID will
come from whatever is in the square
bracket so whatever your name here has
to match this chat ID
then with that let's actually just
display the params
right within the params you can actually
obtain the chat ID so let me just
display the chat ID here
so if I save it here I should show uh
index of ID of one so if you go to like
let's say ID of four then we can see
it's four right so in this case the only
chat ID of one exist so let's actually
uh do the styling for this
so the first thing here I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna try to get the uh cons user ID
from
the auth a weight off from clerk slash
next year's so to use this as we have to
convert this into a server component by
marking as async so we'll do cons user
ID okay then we're gonna check if not
user ID so if they are not authenticated
we don't want them to be here so we can
just return redirect so this redirect
comes from next slash navigation
redirect them to a slash sign in okay
then we're gonna try to get all the
chats that the user has right so because
when the show like the sidebar the chat
sidebar right you can see it show the
chat sidebar with all your chats right
all these chats let's actually get that
page so we'll do uh cons underscore
chats equals to await DB right DB from
our uh from our drizzorm.select
uh
from a chats which imports from the
schema right let me just put this aside
a little bit more
where
right we're going to do equal so this
equal comes from drizzle orm so equal
when chats.user ID
equals to user ID
all right so this is very similar to a
normal sql7 so select from chats where
chat dot user ID equals to user ID so
make sure that you can see the
difference between these chats and these
underscore chats this chat actually
comes from the schema so if we uh press
and V see this is the schema that we
have defined right therefore we will
access the user ID here whereas these
underscore chats is the list of all the
chats that returns from the database
okay so with that we can check if not
chats so if uh basically there isn't any
chats which is the return redirect to a
slash okay
but then the thing is if within the chat
there isn't a valid check ID right that
means we couldn't find the chat ID
within the owner's chats then obviously
something is wrong again so if not
underscore chats.find
ID equals to chat ID so if you can't
find a valid chat ID right so what's the
issue here right now this um uh let me
see this chat ID is an integer it's a
number so we actually want to parse this
into a
parse this into an integer so pass ins
yeah so if I couldn't find anything I'm
gonna do the same return redirect to
slash okay
so with that let's actually start
styling it uh let's do return I'm gonna
have a upper div a very big diff here
there's a cast name of
Flex Max high off screen and overflow of
scroll
off scroll okay
then within this uh within this uh diff
let's actually have this uh another div
this diff will have the class name of
also
fax a width of food
Max height of screen also as well as
over flow scroll
okay
so then within that big diff we have a
smaller div so we'll speed it up in
three sections
uh let me just label it so that we can
see it properly so we have a chat
sidebar
chat sidebar then we have the main PDF
viewer and then we have the chat
component for them to chat with the with
changeability okay so within the first
div here let's give you a class name of
of slack dash one so it's gonna take up
one one unit of space we'll give you a
Max width of Xs
and then we'll just create a
chat we want to have a chat
uh site
bar component so we'll create this
component later
for the PDF viewer for this div we'll
give you a class name of
Max height of of screen
padding of four overflow or screw as
well
and then Flex off five so it takes up
five units of space instead so we have a
PDF
viewer here so we'll create a
componentator for this chat component
lastly for for the div that's wrapping
it will give you a class name of flex Z3
so it takes up three initial Space
Border uh left of four and bolder left
of slate 200. then we have the chat
component okay
so let's create a chat sidebar first so
come down to your components folder chat
uh chat site bar dot TSX
so tsra fce to create the the sidebar
itself
okay so this sidebar is going to take in
uh a few props it's going to take in uh
the list of chats and the active chat ID
so we want to have all the chats here
but also want to know which check is the
active one so for this we want to check
in the chats so be a list of chat but
how do we know where this chat what's
the type of the chat right how do you
get the the type for the chat
if you come back to our schema.ts we can
actually export the type out from the
schema right so we can actually do
um how do we get this okay so in order
to get the type of these chats we can
export
a type called uh uh drizzle chat and we
can do type of uh chat dot dollar sign a
dollar sign infer uh select so this will
give us the proper type of chat so we
get all these typescript here so let's
save this and then now let's go back to
our head sidebar so this chat will be a
list of drizzle uh chats so we import it
from our schema right and then uh
obviously we have the chat ID which is a
which is gonna be a number
okay
so with with that uh with that done
let's actually install the chat cyber so
we can obtain a few things we need we
obtain the chat as well as the chats ID
okay so uh for the chat sidebar actually
let us um
uh yeah let's actually just make it into
a client component so later on uh
because we want to have a striped
subscription right so the button that
triggers a subscription requires the
client component
so let's do a wrapping div so this diff
will have a class name of with a full
height of screen
uh padding of four
text Gray of 200. and also background of
gray of 900 so have a darker background
or in this link within this div we have
a link from next slash link
an Access Link sorry
so this will lead us to
you will see it will lead us to href
all right so this will contain a button
sorry button from UI size button you
will see uh create a new chat create a
new chat so when you click on this
button here
here if you see the example it brings
them back to the home page okay So
within this button let's just start it a
little nicer so we have a plus Circle
icon from a lucid react but just plus a
go and then we'll give you a styling of
let's say margin right of two width of 4
and height of 4. so let's save that and
right now we have a
we actually need to import the sidebar
so let us go to page.tsx so let's import
the the chat sidebar okay so let me just
move this down here uncomment this
so let me import this chat sidebar so it
needs a few things right it needs the
chats so these chats will come from this
underscore chats and for the chat ID
will come from plus ins of the chat ID
so means save this and hopefully
something will show up right now okay
okay so now I have a button that shows
new chat
okay so the way I'm gonna do this I'm
going to expand this screen so that well
we will see the whole screen because
it's supposed to be a big layout right
so I'm going to come back to my vs code
instance and we'll go we'll keep coding
okay
so the next step here is for this button
let us actually uh give you a class name
of sorry let's give you a class name of
with a fool border dashed
uh let's give it border of white and
border
so if we save this
right we can now see that hopefully it
will have a nicer styling with a
dashboard around it okay that's perfect
okay so then uh below this link let's
actually map through the map to the
different chats so we'll enclose this
and entire chat array into a flex dot
Flex call which will be a flex column
and we'll give it a gap of two and
margin top of four
within this div let's actually map to
the text so text.map
so for each chat let's see what we want
to return so we're gonna return a
uh we're gonna return a link itself so
this link will have a key of chat.id but
also a href of
ID
right okay
within this link let us have a div right
this div will contain um
class name of rounded LG large uh
then within this div let's actually put
a P tag that is the chat dot PDF name
okay above the P tag let's put a new
nice message Circle icon from Lucy react
let's start it margin of two so let's
save it and then if we come back here
right now it's gonna look kind of weird
because we only have one a chat and also
it's not properly stuck
okay but at least something is is
happening right so let's tell this
paragraph take away so this paragraph
tag we're gonna give it a class name of
uh with a fool overflow of hidden uh
text SM truncate so if it's too long we
want to uh truncate it and we'll do
white space no wrap and also text
ellipses
okay
uh for this uh upper div with the
rounded large uh
just convert this remove this I'm gonna
wrap it into a GSX and I'm going to call
the CN function so remember the CN
function from the from that it created
for us we can use that right now so the
first thing here let's put a rounded
touch let's give it a padding of three
text slit of 300
and also flags and items Center
okay then we're gonna add a second
parameter in the object so I'm gonna put
BG blue of 600 so if it's the active uh
chat so I'm going to put if the chat ID
equals to chat ID so if it's an active
chat I'll give you a background of blue
and give you a text of white
right but if it's not the chat ID then
I'll put hover text white and we'll just
put the negation of that
so if I save it so if it's the active
chat is to be blue so right now because
it is active chat it should be blue so
let's wait for you to reload uh let's
see okay so perfect now it's working so
it's blue color right now
okay so everything's working fine
so let's now comment of the let's come
out of this diff
uh come out of this div that wraps the
flex call
right so let's collapse it so below the
just above the closing diff let's have a
let's actually put some attacks here so
let's put a div uh
this has a custom off position absolute
bottom of four and left of four
and we'll have a
a diff another div that wraps our links
so this link can just uh just bring back
to like home right or then we have a
case of the Slash
and then we can we have another div to
like whatever source code you want just
put source and any logos that you can
put here right so later here we'll be
putting our stripe button
right so then we allow them to upgrade
their account by pressing this button so
I'm going to give you a little styling
so for this a wrapping div here let's
give a style of flex items Dev Center
game of two text of SM text slate of 500
and flex rep
so let's save this and hopefully there's
a nice icon the nice text that shows up
in the bottom left corner so we're just
waiting for it to reload and hopefully
it will load and now we can see that it
just brings us to the home and the
source page
okay so I hope everything is clear
understandable to you for now
okay so we have completed the chat cyber
okay so now that we have completed the
chat cyber let's actually go on to
create the PDF viewer PDF viewer here
okay so I'm gonna come back down to our
vs code instance so we're gonna come
down here and let's create a new
component called PDF viewer.tsx
okay so for the PDF viewer it's going to
be a very simple component right uh
let's just
do the same the same thing so we'll do
TS array fce to create the typescript
component for us
so it's gonna take in a prop right it's
gonna take in the PDF URL so it's gonna
be a type of string so let's just
destructure it here PDF URL
so Google return just a iframe a normal
iframe right this iframe is going to
have a source of the so we're going to
be basically using Google uh I think
Google provides us with a free I don't
know if it's free I don't know how it
works but it's a it allows us to use
Google Docs uh PDF viewer to show our HD
PDF so for the source you just put https
colon such as docs.google.com G view
right they pass in the URL to be our PDF
URL
and then lastly you want to do uh make
sure that embedded equals to true
right then we'll give you a class name
of uh with a full and height of food
that's that's all there is to here so
let me just sorry Hi Off full so save it
come back to our page.tsx here and
remove this PDF viewer let's uncomment
it out import it from our components
passing the PDF URL to be the uh so how
do you actually get the uh sorry how do
you actually get the PDF URL uh let me
see so to get a PDF URL we must get the
current chat so let me let's get the
current check so we do cons currents
chat equals to uh chats.find sorry find
chatware chat dot ID equals to parse ins
chat ID so we're just looping through
the the chats that we get back from the
database and we just find the one that
is matches the chat ID in the URL so
then for the PDF URL we can just pass in
current chat dot uh PDF URL
so this this might be now right so then
we can just do if it doesn't exist we'll
just pass in an empty string so let's
save this and hopefully we're able to
see the runtime doc so I'm gonna just
refresh the page and then we'll be able
to see the the PDF embedded being shown
here
so let's wait for you to load I think vs
codes are low my my computer is running
a little slow here
okay and so yeah it works so now we can
see that the docs is being embedded into
our iframe which is being imported into
our component here
okay so that's for the PDF viewer all
right so uh now that we have completed
the chat sidebar and the the basically
the main PDF viewer let's actually work
on the chat component here so that we're
able to ask any question we want and we
have that nice uh streaming effect back
from chats gbt right so we'll be using
uh Versa AI SDK for this so if you
search for SDK it's a very new SDK that
has just released in uh June yeah in
June 15th so I did a video just
yesterday about this Library so yeah
I'll be walking you through how we
actually create that this whole uh chat
gbd effect from from scratch with the
help of this Library so this Library
actually abstracts away a lot of the the
knowledge needed to create a proper UI
and to actually integrate different
large language models into our
application so I'll be walking you
through that and I'm going to show you
how easy it is to actually create that
charge ability like effect so the first
step here is to actually uh let us
create that track component so right now
here we can see that we have this check
component so let's come down to our
components folder and let's create that
chat to components Dot txx.tsx
so let's save that first
come back to our page on TSX and now we
can just import the
tag component
okay so with that check component let's
actually begin uh begin the thing okay
so uh let me for now I'm gonna go into
my check component I'm gonna make this
into a a client component
okay so another thing I need to do is
I'm going to come down to my terminal
and go install uh let me just move this
here so we will see it mpm install AI so
my face is blocking but here so it's
just a very simple command so this AI is
the Versa SDK so let's just install it
and then let me move myself back here
okay so I'm going to collapse this
so we're gonna first
um set up the UI for this okay so within
this check component let's return a div
with a class name of
um
relative
Max height of screen
and overflow off scroll
within the div uh let us have another
div so this is for the header right so
let's put here a H3
this is chat
uh give will give this classmates sticky
so you'll stick to the top we will give
you a top of zero so it sticks to the
top also and also insert X of zero so
this is a shorthand for basically
putting left of zero and round zero and
then uh let's give it padding of two
background of white and height of fit
fit okay
so this H3 let's give you a class name
of text Dash XL and font of bold
so if we save this right now uh we just
have this uh check component and it's
also if you show the the chat uh message
here soon if you wait for it to compile
and load so let me just let's give you a
second so I'm going to refresh the page
and hopefully it shows up here
okay so the chat is shown here so we
make sure that everything is working and
the PDF still loads okay
that's good
So Below this div here I'm gonna have a
create another component just for the
message a list okay so I'm gonna create
a component later but below that let's
actually create a before
form which in this form will have an
input right so this input let's actually
install the input from so we'll do MPX
chat CN UI at latest add input okay so
then we can uh able to download the
input component from sets yet press
enter and press uh yes when it prompts
you to so it installs it to our local
system
okay
so here let me just import the input
component from our the cui library so
let me just format this oops format okay
so let me just destructure a few things
from uh the Versa SDK so import a few
things from
AI slash react
so actually we only need one thing it's
called use chat so this u-chat actually
gives us a lot of functionality to
create that streaming UI for chat GPT
experience so let's destructure a few
things from this uh use chat feature
function
so we accumulate four things we need
um the input and also the handle input
change okay so for this input that is
passing the value to be input enter on
change to B handle
input change so all these two things are
doing is is giving control to Versa is
giving control to GPT to control the
input here
and then for the form so whenever we
submit on submit right we can actually
destructure one more function here for
handle submit so it just helps us like
deals with all the different submit uh
submit uh
functionalities for us okay so then uh
with this form completed right let's
let's go into the input let's start with
a little better so we give a placeholder
of ask any question
and let's give you a class name off with
full
okay
so uh for this uh for this form uh let's
actually give you a few class names uh
we give you a sticky so I want to stick
to the bottom of the screen so bottom of
zero inside X of zero pending X of 2
pending y of 4 and background of white
okay below this input let's have a
button
uh this button from your access button
let's just put a
send icon send sorry send icon from Lucy
Dash react we give you a costume of
height of 4 and width of four
the button was a class name of BG blue
of 600 and also margin level of 2.
so I'm going to save this and okay so
right now is it has an input showing up
so we'll wait for the the styles to
update and then it will show up in the
UI so while that is happening okay so
what this use chat function does for us
is that it actually gives us back one
more last thing is the messages array so
this is where the meant to happens this
messages array is a array of messages
and basically what it does is it just uh
it allows us to look through these
messages and displays it in our front
end however we like so if you actually
inspect these messages so let's just do
messages
index 0 and we do dot we can see that
the content we can even see the row
right so this content is like uh the
text content of it but the row here we
can see that it can either be a system
or user right so a system is like the AI
replied and the user is whatever we send
to the gbt So based on whether it's a
system or user we can render different
uh styles for messages so this executive
we're gonna do for the message this
component so what I'm gonna do here it's
gonna come down to uh comes down to my
component and for other components let's
create the message uh list dot TSX
let's do tf's rafc
Okay so
create a component
so the first thing is let's save this
and let's actually import the message
list message
list component from our component
and remember I want to pass in the
message I just want to pass in these
messages from the use chat hook that we
got from Versa SDK
so let me just go into message list
okay for the message list for the props
let us actually get the messages
it's gonna be type of message so this
message type will come from AI slash
react which is perfect so it's going to
be an array of messages
so let's actually destructure the
messages
so then let's do the styling so uh I'm
gonna do
if not messages I'm gonna just return a
empty fragment
so other than that if messages do exist
let's do a creative with a class name of
flex Flex Dash call
gap of 2 and padding X of four okay so
uh yes yes yes okay cool
then within here within this div let's
actually map through the messages
dot map for each message let us just um
return a
a diff
uh with a key of message dot ID
so let's close this diff off right
within this div uh let's actually give
you a few class names class name okay
so we're using the CN function from
utils so for now it's going to be a flex
box right but the thing is
uh we're gonna justify it to the end
and
If the message dot row equals to user so
what it does is saying is that if it's a
user message I'm gonna push the message
all the way to the right of the screen
right so let me just show you how it
will look like so if you come back to
the original here we can see that
because it's a it's a user message I
post it I align the message to the right
if it's an email message I push it to
the left
right now why is this button here
misaligned so let's let's look at why
there is check component so I think what
I did here was I forgot to wrap it in
another
uh Flex box right yep so here inside
this form I should wrap it into another
flexbox that wraps the input and the
button so that it aligns together
so in the meantime we're passing the
messages into the message list
okay so let's save it so now let's go
back to coding okay
so if if it's a air Message let's
actually just do justify Dash start
If the message dot row equals to
assistant
okay so let's add one more style here
we're gonna give you a padding left of
10 and padding rate of 10 below here so
within this div we can actually display
the message content
so we have a div
uh
which will have a class name of rounded
off large
okay
within the uh rounded latch let's
actually create a paragraph tag that
shows the message dot content
okay
and then here actually for this div
instead of putting into a string like
this put in GSX because you want to use
a CN function so firstly if you can have
the uh rounded that's large that doesn't
change but for the second object we
actually want to color it blue If the
message row is user so um BG sorry BG
Dash blue dash 600 and text of white
If the message row equals to user right
so for the other than rounded large
let's give it some more style so
planting X of 3
text SM
heading y of 1 shadow of medium
ring one ring Dash gray Dash 900 divided
by 10 right so let's save this and
that's uh that's it for the message list
okay so that's good that's good so right
now obviously we will not be able to see
anything because we do not have any
messages showing up right so how do we
actually do the messages
so how it works is that if you come back
to this chat component we can see that
this use chat right by default Let's see
we can show you we can actually add some
more configuration in the object so we
can pass in a lot more data like uh the
API so this API is going to default to
slash API chat
okay so we have to actually create this
endpoint so that uh whenever we hit
enter it will send the in the message to
our chat gbd endpoint and then it will
return us with a streaming output from
chat GPT
so let's create this endpoint so I'm
Gonna Save It come down to our app right
under API let's create a chat folder and
inside let's press root.ts okay
so the root of TS is going to be pretty
simple right so first here is import
let's import from open eih so because
we're using the open AI model so open
Con uh import configuration and also
open AI API
so we do the same thing right we'll do
cons config
equals to new configuration
right passing in the API key to be
processed or EnV to open AI API key so
we already uh got the API key just now
so we can leave it there then we'll do
cons open AI equals to new open AI con
API passing the config so one more thing
here is I'm gonna do export cons runtime
equals to eight so these were the eight
runtimes comes in right because we're
using the open AI age we can actually
mark this function as a h so H function
H function so that you make this
function much faster when we actually
deploy it to versa
okay so now let's actually export a
async function called
uh post we're going to in request to be
the request
so how this works is we're gonna first
get the body so uh I'm gonna do a try
catch block
so we didn't try to get the body equals
to a weight request.json okay so in the
body we can actually destructure a few
things once the structure the messages
array so whatever the check component
right this will handle all the logic for
us whenever we press submit on the input
it's going to uh send the current
messages into our slash API chat which
we will receive in these messages uh
request body okay then once we have the
message right messages array let us do
uh we ask open AI for streaming chat
completion so we do cons response
response equals awaits uh open AI sorry
awaits open AI dot create chat
completion right passing three things we
need a model so the model will be using
GPD 3.5 Dash turbo so it's it's a very
fast model but it's also very
um uh how's it competent then we'll set
we're passing the messages array uh so
this comes from the request body and
lastly we want to set streaming to be
true
so because we want uh like token to come
back one by one so what streaming means
is that let's say I send a request to
open AI instead of waiting it for it to
generate the whole response and then
sending it back at once and we have to
wait for like maybe a few seconds
the moment the a starts generating
tokens One Word by one word it will
start sending the one word by one word
back to me and able to display on the
front end okay so to actually create
that streaming effect all right uh for
cell AI actually give us utility
functions to create this to get the
response stream and convert it to a
normal stream to our front end so let's
import two things from the AI Library
itself so this AI is from the Versa SDK
so we need the open AI stream and also
the streaming text response uh utility
function here
so first let's get the stream to we
basically call the open AI stream
function open AI stream and pass in the
response then lastly we can return a
return a new streaming text response
passing in the Stream so it will take
the streaming response from open Ai and
passes it back to our front end
then let us save this
right and look at the magic here right
and believe it or not this all it takes
for you to create to create LGBT right
so now if I try it ask any questions so
right now let me ask like
hello I send it right we should be able
to see the charge ability slowly
answering back so let's wait for the
check I can see look it works and that's
incredible like we didn't really write
any like custom code all we need to do
was call some functions from the virtual
AI SDK it's able to create that chat
streaming effect for me so I can ask
like um how is uh sorry explain
JavaScript
uh run time to me
so we can see that there's a streaming
effect from uh LGBT so what it does is
it hits the back end it hits the it says
API says chat then it creates the
streaming effect and then basically
sends it to your front end and then it
updates the messages array right so
remember here these messages that we got
from this huge chat right update the
messages then we pass it to the message
list and then we look through the
message list and depending on whether it
was the AI responding or the user
responding we're able to create this
beautiful this beautiful response right
so the issue right now is that yes
although we have a nice chargeability
interface going on this charge ability
has no idea about the PDF right it
doesn't know any idea about what the PDF
is talking about so uh in the next part
here we're gonna start trying to fit the
context of the PDF into the 3gp response
so that it has contacts of the PDF okay
so uh so now that we have this strategy
interface right the issue right now is
that uh it doesn't have context about
the PDF so let's go back to escalator to
see what we're gonna do next
so remember now that we have all these
Vector embeddings documents stored
within our Pinecone DB right so how do
we actually get the relevant uh the
relevant back that embedding for
whenever we ask a question so let me
let's say the second part right see this
search part so the first step here is to
embed the queries then we're gonna query
the Pinecone DB for similar vectors so
then we're going to take maybe like the
top five similar vectors we're gonna
extract out the metadata of the similar
vectors so we can take out the text
content of the five top five similar
vectors and then we'll fit the whole
paragraph of contacts into the open AI
prompt so if you come back to the if you
come back to our function here in within
the the chat root right here whenever we
do this uh uh we get the create check
completion right for these messages
right we can actually get uh get another
prompt so we can have a additional
problem such that we're able to give the
open AI context of uh the the PDF so
that's what we're gonna do next so let's
just open our directory and let's create
that function to get the context so I'm
going to close up everything and come
down to our lip and let's create a new
file called
context.ts so this context.ts it's going
to mainly have two functions right so
it's going to have two functions the
first function is going to be called uh
export async uh function get contact so
this is the actual function to get the
context of the query so we're taking the
query which is a string right so this
query is is basically what is being
passed whenever we ask a question like
in this chat box here okay
uh and the second thing is we want to
have the file key right so remember why
we need a file key because we need the
name space so remember I introduced you
I introduce the time we talked about
uh we need this namespace so not just
now whenever we push uh vectors within
the pine cone we actually added a
namespace prop right so now we need to
get the correct namespace so that we
search the vector DB for the correct
within the correct name phase so that
we're not searching for information from
other PDFs right so therefore we need we
also need this file key to get the
correct namespace
so then uh to do this let us first so we
also need a function export uh
let me see so this second function will
be called get matches
from m paddings
so this step this function will take in
embeddings so it's a vector so it's an
array of number and also the found key
which is a string
so this function is going to basically
take the the query Vector it's going to
search through the pine cone for the top
five similar vector and then it's going
to it's going to return me with the top
five similar factors so I'm going to
write out a code and then we'll see what
it means all right so the first thing
here I'm gonna do is
um for this Gap methods from embeddings
so I'm going to be quarrying pine cone
right so I need the Pinecone Clan
right then we'll do awaits a pine cone
dot in it
right so we need the API key which is
pine cone API key and so that it exists
and we also need the environment right
this environment is going to be the
pine cone environment so make sure you
have this within your EnV here
right so we did it just now so it's fine
so make sure this exists so this will be
environment okay
so after initializing Pinecone let's get
the index right the pine cone index we
do a weight pine cone dot index so the
index remember what you name it I name
it uh chat PDF right so it's the one
that corresponds to within your Pinecone
console chat PDF Okay so now that we got
this index let's do a try catch block so
if it fails let's just do console.log
uh error querying uh embeddings then we
just pass in the error
then we just true the arrow back to the
color
true error okay
so I'll try so first we get the
namespace
so remember the namespace we have to
convert the file key into s key
characters
so we import that from YouTube and we
pass in the file key
and then we want to initialize a
consular
query request
right so uh so sorry query result so
this query result is going to be uh the
function it's gonna get back from this
function called index.query so pine cone
index actually has a function called
query right so if you go into the object
we can see that we need a query request
object
so with this query request object we can
pass in a lot of other vectors that we
want to search for so this top K
basically get uh tells is asking python
how many vectors will be on the return
so if you print top put top K as 5 is
asking is saying that you want to return
us with the top five similar vectors
that matches the query embedding
then we pass in the vector that we
actually want to query against which is
the embedding just passed into this uh
uh parameter and then we want to include
metadata so that we can get back the
text uh the original text from the query
the similar vectors and we pass into
namespace which is from the convert to
as key
so this query result you can see that
it's going to be a query response so we
can then return query result dot matches
IELTS and M3 so this method is going to
return us with the top 5 Squad Vector so
it's gonna be an array of five vectors
because we put in top ks5 right so then
we're going to return this if not we
just if we say empty array
okay so now that we have this function
we can actually call this get matches
from embedding within this get contact
function here
so I'm gonna do cons query uh embeddings
it goes away
get embeddings so we've written this
function using open AI right then we're
passing the query string right and then
now we can actually call this above
function so we do cons matches equals to
a weight gets matches from embeddings
pass in the query embeddings and the
file key
okay so this matches will be returned
from this recovery without the matches
then we can do cons uh cons qualifying
docs equals to matches
dot filter
so for each match uh for each match
we're gonna return the
um we're gonna return if match DOT score
exists we're going to return match DOT
score bigger than 0.7
right so what this does is basically it
will Loop through all the matching uh
matching vectors so if the score matches
more than 70 percent then we'll return
it so if it's less than 70 it's probably
irrelevant so we just want to ignore
that okay then lastly we can type the
metadata so remember the metadata type
meta data
we have a text which is a string and as
well as a page number which is a number
okay so with that we can then do like
docs equals to matches
dot map
uh matches uh sorry
we can actually do qualifying docs dot
map for each match
we can do uh match dot metadata
as metadata so we customly type it dot
text
so what it does is if you go through
each docs right then because remember we
added the metadata before pushing into
pine cone then we can just get back the
text then lastly we want to return
docs.join sorry
Docs
dot join
a slash n so basically let's say we get
back five uh five vectors right the five
factors we're gonna basically take the
five paragraphs from each the five
vectors then we're just gonna join it
together
then that's going to be the context
Block in which we fit into open AI
prompt then we're gonna substring it to
zero to three thousand so in case that
the docs is it exceeds three thousand
characters we'll just cut it off because
we don't want to fit too much
information into open AI because then
the token limit might be reached right
so let's save this so we've actually
completed this function
okay so then let's come back to our
chats uh route
so now within here we can actually get
the context or we didn't get the
contacts here okay so the first thing
here what we're gonna do is we need the
file key right so remember what I'm
going to do is we want to get the last
message last message
equals to
messages or message dot length minus one
so the last message is the message that
is sent in by the user so this last
message is the query itself
so how do we get the context so context
equals to
await gets contacts right we import it
from our library contacts so get last
message right
which is a query but how do you get the
file key right right now we we can't get
the file key from this request body
right so this power key has to actually
come from the chat itself right so to
get that file key we actually need to go
back to our check component right so
underneath this use chat right there's
another parameter that we can pass in
which is the body right so these
additional objects that can be passed
back to our backend here whenever we
make the call so we can pass in a chat
ID right so how do you get the chat ID
we can get it from props
so let me just type it out first and
then we're able to I'll explain uh how
the entire flow works
so we need the check ID so if you come
back to our
page.tsx we need to pass in this chat ID
to chat ID
in parse and chat ID
uh okay that works then save it so from
our page.tsx we're passing the chat ID
to our check component we're receiving
in props and basically this use chat
will pass it into the body so that we
can destructure it from uh the request
body at the back end here a chat ID so I
hope you get the flow of it okay so how
do we get the file key from the chat ID
we can we can query the database for
this right so we do cons underscore
chats equals to awaits DB so this from
drizzle RM dot select
Dot from chats
where so these chats have to import from
schema also where
equals a
chats.id equals to
chat ID okay yep
so then we're gonna check if uh chats
dot length
not equals to one so if there's not
exactly one chat something went wrong
we're just gonna return a uh return a
next next response
dot Json
I'm sorry let's import this
saying that error
chat not
found
passing in a status off
404.
okay
so everything looks good okay so now
that we've got the chats right we can
obtain the chat so cons uh file key
equals to underscore chats index zero
because we are basically getting back a
list of all the chats that fulfill these
requirements right so we do underscore
chats dot file key so this is how we
obtain the file key
okay then we can just pass in the file
key into our contacts so now this
context should return us with a whole
paragraph of relevant vectors and their
page content so with that we can
actually now finish into the response so
I'm gonna just do uh cons prom
equals to an uh to uh turn object where
the row will be a system so This Is Us
Now feeding the context into charge gbt
so I'm going to copy base this problem
because uh I wrote uh I didn't write it
but I got it from somewhere I got it
from the Versa AI docs right so the I'm
going to paste this in let me just
let me just work okay so basically what
it does is it tells us the rows the
system and tells you the content is that
is telling the AI that is a powerful
human-like Ai and basically what it does
is he pass in the context block right so
this context you can see that in
templates it in within a prom it tells
you that AI assistant will take into
account any context block that is
provided in the conversation yeah sorry
I'll post this uh I'll post this prompt
into uh in the description below so you
don't have to manually write it out
yourself
okay so now that we have this problem we
cannot feed it into the response of this
create chat completion so for these
messages right other than just passing
in the messages from the request body
I'm also going to map through I'm going
to pass in the prompt itself as well as
uh all the messages
all the messages
dot filter
message
dot uh
message dot role equals to user
so this message will have a type of
a message which comes from AI slash
react so let me import that from ESS
react
okay so what this does is basically uh
for these messages array that pass that
is being passed into open AI I pass in
the prompt which is this entire context
block right it contains all the relevant
documents as well as I pass in all the
messages that only belongs to the user
right so we only care about what the
user is asking so if the messages
contains any uh assistant messages we
just block that out so that we can save
some contacts always I'm sorry we save
some token space when we create the
check completion
so I hope you understand and then lastly
I think that's pretty much it we
completed so then we can save this file
come back to Tech component right come
and check command and let's see if
anything else uh is required okay so uh
one last thing here down to add is
um let me see uh let me see let me see
let me see so whenever uh whenever the
message is being uh a send right it's
being uh basically entered I want to
scroll down scroll all the way down
right because if not like let's say I
answer ask a question right it does not
Auto manually scroll down for me
so to do that what I can do is I'm going
to come back up to a um
let me see let me see a message uh okay
under our check component so for our
wrapping div here I'm going to give you
an ID of message container
then I'm gonna add a react dot use
effect
right
so basically every time the message
change messages change I'm gonna do
document uh cons message container it
goes to
document.getelement by ID
right so I'm gonna get the ID of this
div then if the message container exists
right then I'm gonna do message
container Dot scroll
uh scroll to
sorry the scroll to the top should be
message container the scroll height and
behavior should be smooth
okay so this will basically
automatically screw us down to the
bottom of the message whenever there's a
new message that comes in so if we save
everything right and let's hope that it
works so I'm gonna just refresh the page
right now okay so I'm gonna try
everything from scratch to make sure
that everything is still working as
intended so
I'm gonna press a new chat and I'm gonna
wait for you to bring me back to the
home page upload my own custom document
and let's test if it works okay so I'm
gonna do drop PDF here so let me select
a relevant PDF let's say I ask about my
resume because at least that's something
I know will work so it's gonna be
uploading it to uh chat GP it will
upload to S3 then you upload to uh
Pinecone so let's wait for a while
because it's running locally it's going
to be a little slower but when we push
it up to Versa this process is going to
be really really fast so let's wait for
it to load
so let me see if everything is looking
fine
okay so chat has been created we can see
that the resume has been uploaded I can
see my resume here and so by right if I
ask the question it should take into
context my my PDF so let me ask uh
uh what school did Elliot attend
question mark
so let's wait for you to respond and
hopefully
is able to give me something insightful
but something is breaking so let's look
at the error
okay I cannot read undefined text Dot
replace is not a function ever calling
open AI embeddings API so let's see why
that is the issue ah okay so I see the
issue right now you can see the last
message is uh this is an object itself
right but then it release we should be
really getting the message or content
right instead of passing the whole last
message so let's pass in the message or
content
so let's save this so hopefully that
explains the error so yeah I'll be
debunking like this okay so this should
work now so I can ask where did edits
attend school question mark So if I send
this hopefully if everything goes right
okay yes that's awesome so he's able to
see that it has gotten out the context
from my education uh Vector within my uh
PDF is able to give me an insightful
answer
okay so let me ask like let's say how
many projects
did he do
so we save that and Okay so okay so I
mean obviously it's not perfect but it's
able to get in contact within the PDF
and that's uh that's really exciting for
me here okay okay so the issue right now
is that everything is working perfectly
however the moment I refresh right you
can see that the chat log doesn't get
saved right because we're not saving the
chat store database so how to actually
save the chat store database it's a
really simple thing and that's what I
really love about the versaillou AI sck
so if you come back to our uh you see
this uh open AI stream right it actually
accepts the second parameter which is an
object and within this object it create
it gives us a lot of hooks hooks and
callbacks so we can see that on start so
basically what this uh function this
callback does is that whenever uh the
query has started it's gonna give us
that prompt right it's gonna give us the
it's gonna tell us that it started and
then we can save the prompt into our
database right that means we can save
the user's message within our database
so what we're gonna do is on start with
a
safe user message into DB right then the
second one is on completion so whenever
the the ai ai finish responding it's
gonna give us the a completion and then
we can then uh save this into a database
so then save AI message into DB
so let's do that it's a very simple call
so we just do a wage DB dot insert
right insert into our messages sorry
messages
so we can see that messages right now is
importing from uh from the request body
but actually we want the messages from
our drizzle of schema so let's get that
so instead of this chat let's also
import the messages and we can rename it
to underscore messages so that the
naming doesn't collide okay so we're
going to insert into messages dot values
right it's going to take an object so we
can see the different attributes we need
so we need first we need a chat ID so we
have that from the request body so
that's perfect
then we also need the content so we can
get that from lastmessage.content so
this is the user query and then we can
do the row which is a user okay then
whenever it has completed so that we can
save the AI message into our database we
do this write something very similar so
for this content it's just literally
completion so completion is just a
normal string
okay then that's pretty much it so we
have successfully saved the message into
our database okay so how do we actually
access the messages whenever we first
load here okay just a very simple thing
to do let's also create let's create a
new Roots within our API called uh gets
Dash messages sorry let's create a
folder called get Dash messages
will create a roots.ts underneath here
okay
so inside this root is a really simple
function we just want to return all the
messages for a given chat ID okay so
we'll do export cons post equals to an
uh async function
this will take in the request
uh request object okay
so it's just gonna we're gonna get the
body from await request.json
so we're going to destructure the chats
ID from the request body and then we'll
just do cons messages it goes to await
DB so we'll import this DB uh from adlib
and then we can do dot select
Dot from messages
so this messages can be import from
schema dot where equals
messenger messages dot chat ID it goes
to the check ID plus angular request per
app so it really is like SQL so Json RM
is cool in this in this sense so
actually we can also Mark this uh export
uh confront time equals H to make this
function faster when we deploy it
because drizzle is compatible to age
runtime that's why we can do this
then we just want to return next
response uh
dot Json
Plus in the messages okay so let's save
this so now we're gonna call this
function call this root from the front
end right so this check component we can
see that for this use chat right there's
one more thing that will actually pass
into this uh check component within our
object here we can pass in
um
uh other than the body here we can pass
in an initial message messages which can
be an array right so how do you get back
these initial messages we can just do a
call to our endpoint just now
so we'll do that from a use Query so
this from react query again use Query
okay we're passing the query key right
so this key is to uniquely identify this
code this query made to the back end
right so we'll query the chat ID and
then so this can be anything right this
is not important the query key doesn't
make much of a different so the query
function is what is being called to get
the messages
so we'll do um cons
response equals awaits uh axios dot post
to slash API slash get messages
right we can pass inter chats ID right
and then we can pass in a generic so
that this will always ensure that it's
going to be a message
a message array so then this this
message array that we get back here this
response.data so let me just return
response.data we can see that this
responsible data will have a type of
message array then we can just pass in
this data so let's destructure the data
from here this data will have the
message array right and with this
initial message we can just pass it here
uh data is not passing the MD array yeah
that's all there is right so one more
thing here is uh let's just save that
first and let's make sure that it works
okay so I'm going to uh refresh the page
I'm going to refresh the page and then
I'm gonna wait for it to load and then
I'm gonna ask the question and hopefully
it saves my query to the database okay
so I'm gonna ask you a question like uh
where did he intern at question mark
okay so it should return me with the
response then if I refresh the page
hopefully this chat will okay so it
works so when I refresh the page we can
see that it gets the messages that
stopped within the database it passes it
passes the array into the use message
hook so that it renders the initial
messages
that's good so one more slide UI
Improvement that I just want to make
it's a very simple one it's just two
while I'm touching the data is loading
so again it's loading from this use
Query I'm gonna pass it into my uh
message this so pass is loading to is
loading okay I'm gonna go into my
message list I'll accept this as props
is loading it's gonna be a Boolean okay
then I just want to if it's loading I
just want to show a loading spinner
that's pretty much what I want to do so
I'm gonna show if it's loading so let's
destruct it from the props itself
it's loading
I'm gonna return a div
uh sorry
so I'm gonna return a div with position
absolute
right we'll give you a custom of top of
half
left sorry left of half negative
translates X of half negative translates
y of half then inside here I'm going to
put a loader a loader two imported from
Lucid react
let's give you a classic Mode width of 6
high of 6 and and made spin so this is
just that when he's loading the initial
messages it will there's a nice loading
effect or refresh the page again
okay so I guess that's a side fetch of
the loader if you can see carefully but
yeah so that's that's pretty much uh
what we need to do to get the uh
database to save the chat blocks
all right so we're almost we're
basically done with the project like the
main functionality of the chat to BDF
has been finished uh we have been fully
implemented by now so the last part here
is I'm going to teach you how to
implement stripe into this uh product to
really make it into a software as a
service for you to Market it and improve
on it okay so the first step to uh
integrating stripe is let's install the
stripe package so we'll do npm install
stripe okay then let us come down to uh
let's actually clear out all the files
here so that we start crash okay so come
down into your schema.ts here we're
going to create a new user subscription
schema to store a record of whether a
user has paid for the pro subscription
or not okay so uh within your schema.ts
we're gonna we're gonna export a new
sorry export a new uh table called user
subscription so export cons user
subscriptions equals to a PG table
user uh sub sorry user subscriptions
right and then for within the object The
Columns will have ID so the serial ID
which is a primary key we have a user ID
which is a varchar of a user ID and let
us just give you a length of
256 characters okay uh
then we have a sorry we have to make
this note now as well as this Shield has
to be unique sorry unique okay
then for the user ID uh we have a stripe
customer ID right this will be a VAR
chart as well we'll give you a strap
customer ID and then we'll have a link
of also 256 okay this has also not to be
not now as well as unique okay
then we have a stripe uh sub scription
ID it's gonna be a VAR chart of of
stripe subscription ID
a let's give you a length of 256 however
this time this field could be now so
yeah but we still have to be unique then
we have a stripe of price stripe price
ID a voucher map to stripe price ID
within the database will give you a
length of 256 and this could be now also
then lastly we have a stripe
current period and
uh let's give you a timestamp of striped
card appearance n and let's make this uh
nullable so with that out of the way
let's save this file so we have created
this user subscription table so now
let's actually push it to our database
so we'll do the same thing MPX uh
drizzle kit push
uh Dash PG right so let me move myself
out of this way mpx3 so kit push with a
PG command so we have already done this
before so with that let's just press
enter and hopefully that it works okay
so changes has been applied so perfect
so the migration has has worked so now
let's close the terminal so now a new
table has been created within the neon
database
okay so come on to your folder come down
to your lip let's create a stripe dot TS
so this is gonna uh contain our
initialization of the stripe Library
so the first thing here is let's import
Stripe from the stripe package that we
installed from npm
then let's export cons stripe equals to
a new stripe uh stripe passing in the
process.env dot stripe API key
a string and then the second object the
configuration will pass in the API
version
right to be whoever they ask you to
enter and type script to be true okay so
let me just spell this right const and
save it all right so uh to get the API
key let's come down to our browser
go to stripe uh console just search for
stripe console within Google
and come down to the first link here
stripe login the dashboard
and all you can do is you can create a
stripe account if you have not if you
have you just log in so in this case I
already signed in
right and the first thing you want to do
is come down to the top left hand corner
so I'm going to zoom in a little
and then I need to create a new account
and name this whatever you want so I'm
gonna name it chat PDF Dash YouTube
country of operation choose the one that
you are based off then create account so
you might need to enter your password
sometimes to access the new part of the
dashboard
so after creating the account you should
be able to relate to the developers page
right so come to press the developers
and you should be able to see your API
keys
okay so this is the secret key so we
need the secret key so review the secret
key and just click to copy to your
dashboard to your I mean your clipboard
then we'll come back to our env.env so
let me just uh come down here and let's
do stripe
so just enter stripe
API key let's enter it here the S key as
key test
let's save it and let's close the file
okay that's good so now we need to come
down to our folder come down to our uh
API and let us create a new folder
called a stripe
within that let's create the roots.ts
okay okay so this will map to slash API
stripe so whether we're calling this
backend right to actually create the
payments and create the like billing
accounts okay
so uh with this slash actually start
writing a code for the stripe endpoint
all right so the first thing I want to
do is uh
export a async function called get so be
a get request
so we'll do a try catch block so the
first thing you want to do is we're
going to get the authenticated user
awaits off so this comes from the XCS so
we've done this before we'll get the
user ID okay
so now they have the user ID we can
check for the user cons user equals to
await a current user so this is also a
function from uh clerk slash nextges
then we're gonna check if not user ID
that means they're not authenticated
let's return a new next response
telling you that is unauthorized and
passing a status off forward
so if their authentication created let's
actually check for their user
subscription have they subscribed to the
account so if they have subscribed to
the to the pro account that means
they're trying to cancel the account of
change that subscription but if they
have not subscribed there is if there's
no role within the database that means
we know that they are trying to
subscribe for the first time so let's uh
get the cons user subscription
equals to await DB from drizzle dot
select
Dot from user subscriptions so this
comes from schema uh dot where
equals so we check the users
subscriptions dot user ID equals to the
user ID pass in from clerk here
okay so if uh user subscriptions at
index 0
uh right
and the end user subscriptions at index
0 dot extract customer ID so if the
customer ID exists with your database
that means they are subscribed that
means they are trying to cancel
trying to cancel
at the billing portal that's we're gonna
do get corn stripe session equals to a
weight stripe so this is from our lip
stripe dot billing portal dot sessions
dot create right passing the customer to
be user subscriptions index 0.stripe
customer ID
and then the return URL let's just uh
let's actually make it into a variable
up here so cons return URL to be
process.env.next a public URL
uh sorry this can be named to next base
URL so let's create the EnV variable
so let's put under here next base URL so
this is where we want it to redirect to
if they cancel or if they finish the
transaction in stripe so for now the
HTTP localhost 3000 then when we deploy
to Versa obviously we want to put it as
the result URL okay so let's save this
so this will be next base URL plus slash
right so we're going to return it to the
uh the return URL
okay then after that we can just return
a
next response
dot Json passing the URL to base track
session dot stripe session dot URL
okay
however if this is not the first if this
is not the case then this is the users
so first time trying to subscribe
okay
so if that's the case let us do
cons stripe session it goes to await
stripe dot checkout dot sessions dot
create so for the success URL we can
pass in just a return URL
okay
for the cancel URL we're also going to
pass in the return URL
uh then for the payment method uh
payments
method types we'll just pass in one type
which is the card there's no accept card
then for the mode you'll be subscription
subscription
for the billing address collection let's
put it to auto
for the customer email customer email
will pass in a user dot email addresses
so one user might have a lot of email
addresses
index 0 we take the first one the email
address okay then we will do line items
so this is a list of items you want to
buy so in this case there's only one
item right which is the subscription
so you'll be price data right this could
be object the currency let's put it as
USD
like USD
for the product data sorry product data
is gonna be object the name will be
chats PDF uh Pro
with the description being
on
unlimited PDF sessions
then also have the product here
outside the product data let us put unit
amount to be 2000 which represents 200
dollars uh not 200 20 a month then
recurring will set to uh object of the
interval meaning the months okay so it
will recur every month so that's how the
subscription works
and then outside of the price data right
also have the price data
will put the quantity as one
okay then finally uh finally outside of
the line items right so outside items
within this array right we'll pass the
metadata
right passing the user ID so we need
this user ID because later on whenever
whenever we finish this uh transaction
right stripe is going to send a web hook
back to our API endpoint again and
within the endpoint we need to be able
to access who actually did the
transaction that's why we need this user
ID metadata here
so lastly after this trip session has
been created let's just return a next
response dot Json passing in the URL to
be stripe session.url okay so if there's
any errors let's just console.log a
stripe error
passing the error and we'll just return
a new
uh return the new next response
saying that internal server error
with a status of 500.
okay so let's save this first okay so
let's actually try writing out uh try
using this uh endpoint in our
in our web application so if you come
down to our
chat sidebar right let's come down to
our chat sidebar
chat sidebar right we'll have a button
below here below the strike button here
that actually displays uh that actually
displays our strike button so what I'm
going to do here is I'm gonna wrap this
entire thing into a
sorry I'm gonna move the strike button
outside of this and let me give it a
button
okay of class name of margin top of two
okay this button will have a class name
of a
text white and BG slate 700
okay
and then he's gonna say upgrade
to
Pro
okay so then let's create a function uh
for the what happens when we click on
the button so cons handle subscription
right what happens is we want to make an
async function
right we're going to do tri-cat
so let us have a sorry what's the issue
here
okay here should be like this so we have
a state for the loading state right when
it's loading the backend so first we
will do set loading to be sorry set
loading to be true then finally we want
to set loading to be
false okay
so uh what we're gonna do is do cons
response equals to
a weight
uh axios dot get slash API subscribe so
this will hit the end point that we set
up here
root.ts right and remember it's going to
return us with a URL so whether it's URL
from here or URL from here we'll ensure
that there is a URL so we're going to do
window.location.href equals to
response.data dot URL so this is going
to redirect us to the stripe page
so if there's any error let's just
control dot error the error
so let's save this and let's go back to
our uh to our page so I'm gonna refresh
the page and let's hope that the
subscription button shows up and then it
is able to show us a subscription
okay so we can see this upgrade to Pro
button working so what I'm going to do
here is uh I'm gonna disable this button
disable
when it's loading okay so I'm going to
save it
so then let me just refresh the page
again so I think it's just my computer
being slow right now so hopefully this
will work okay so let me just refresh
the page all right
so when I press upgrade to Pro I should
it should disable and then show me any
eventually lead me to the stripe
checkout page so I'm gonna upgrade to
Pro
okay so right now obviously nothing is
happening because I haven't bounded the
uh on click Handler
so let me just do
on click I'm gonna do handle
subscription
so let me save this so whenever I click
on this button I want to actually call
this function up here to redirect me to
the stripe checkout page all right so
let me just refresh the page again so
wait for next GS load so then once it
has loaded so by right if I click on
this button it should lead me to the
checkout page so click on it so now it's
disabled so it's loading the backend
then it's going to create the strap
checkout sessions and return me with the
URL then it's going to redirect me and
replace this whole page without strap
checkout so let's wait for the next yes
to handle to come back
so then okay see it works so we can see
that it's asking us to subscribe to chat
PDF Pro and here we can enter all
details so once we entered it right it's
actually going to help us send a web
hook back to our application so let's
set up the web hook okay so I'm gonna
come back here
uh come back to obvious code come back
to our directory
We Now app let's create another folder
called webhook
inside here let's do root dot TS
okay so this root.ts will be the webhook
that the that what's that called
uh that stripe is going to send back to
us whenever the transaction succeeds or
whether it failed all right so let us
just do uh export async function post
right it's going to take the request
body
right so this request is going to be
made by stripe itself so that get the
body it goes to a weight request or text
right then we do cons signature so I
want to verify that the web is indeed
coming from stripe itself so we take
haters so this haters function will be
imported from
next slash heaters
it's all haters so invoke it then we'll
do uh
caters dot gets
stripe
signature
s string right then we will initialize
an event like event to be a stripe
dot event okay then let's do a try cash
block
so
uh events equals to stripe
dot webhook so let's import the Stripe
from our like lip folder
swipe.web
uh sorry web hooks
dot construct event
right we're passing the body the sick
nature
sorry sick nature as well as the
process.env.stripe web hook secret so
I'll show you how to get the web hook
Secret in just a bit let's just code it
out first add string
okay so we construct this event and save
it to the event variable here
okay so if there's any errors that means
then the the strike signature didn't
come true that means is uh something
suspicious going on so let's just return
a new next response
right this is webhook error
pass in your status of 400.
okay then lastly we just need to come
out of this
so we can check for the we can check for
the sessions concession equals to events
dot data.object s stripe dot checkout
check out dot session okay
so we're gonna check so if the new
subscription is created we'll do we'll
save it to the database so if
events.type equals to
checkout.session dot completed
okay so if the checkout is completed
we're gonna take con subscription equals
to await stripe dot subscriptions
dot retrieve
okay well done retrieve we're going to
retrieve the session.subscription
subscription string okay
then we'll do we'll check if not session
dot uh metadata dot user ID so remember
this metadata.user ID is what we pass in
uh to the to this metadata here that's
why we need it to show here so if the
user ID doesn't exist uh what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say that okay
something's invalid we'll do return new
next response saying that
uh no user ID okay
then if everything passes we'll just
insert into database so in awaitdb dot
insert user subscriptions from the
schema top values
foreign
so we want the user ID to be the session
dot metadata dot user ID
right
then stripe subscription ID will be the
subscription to ID
so customer ID will be straight a
subscription Dot customer string then
stripe price ID will be subscription dot
items dot data index 0 dot price dot ID
and then lastly we have the stripe
current period n which will be a new
date
and will initialize it to subscription
dot currents period n multiplied by
1000. okay
so we've inserted into the database
right so if it's not the subscription
creator that means the payment has
succeeded so we will check if events the
type equals to uh invoice dot payment
succeeded
right
so if this is the case we do con
subscription equals to await stripe dot
subscription
dot retrieve we're going to retrieve
section.subscription as string okay then
we're gonna do a weight DB dot uh update
user subscriptions right we're gonna set
Buddha said the
stripe price ID to be subscription sorry
a subscription dot items
dot data index 0.price.id
then we set the striped current period
end to the new date subscription or
current period n times 100 so it's the
same thing as above but we're just
updating the common row
right we want to update it where
the user ID sorry the user subscription
dot uh
stripe uh stripe subscription ID equals
to the subscription.id so we're
basically up we're gonna look at the
subscription and we're gonna update the
database based on the where Clause here
okay then finally this is the most
important part when the return a new
next response right of of now and 200.
oh sorry and the status has a b 200. so
the status has to be 200 so that the web
hook knows that uh he has finished his
job so if you don't return these tenses
of 200 strive will think that something
is run wrong and you keep sending your
sending messages to your endpoint until
it gets a success back so that's what
the status 200 is for
okay so now that we got this let us
actually uh add one more thing so come
back to your middleware.ts we need to
add one add this route to the uh we need
to add this middleware slash API says
middleware to the public group because
stripe will be the one that's hitting
this uh middleware so we need to be
public so let's save it and lastly let
us go into our uh stripe uh stripe
endpoint stripe console here
cut up to web hooks come out to web
hooks here and you will need to be able
to test it here so
what's up what's the issue here so let's
cancel this
so I'm just going to start my next GS
server for a ride for now because it's
getting really slow
so come back to your stripe uh
stripe console okay so what we're gonna
do is come down to web hooks we're gonna
test a test in local environment right
so the first step here is to download
the CLI so you can follow the
instructions depending on whether you're
on Windows or you're on Mac or your
Linux so for me I'm on Mac so I did Brew
install right if you're on Mac you can
just follow the instruction uh here
windows Yep so after you've installed
the stripe CLI come come down to your
terminal and do stripe login
extract login so come back to your vs
code instance and just do stripe login
so it will ask you to open this link
within the browser to verify that you
are trying to test your stripe webhook
then just click on allow access
so then you are logged in within the
command line so see that the CLI is
configured
The Next Step here is
stripe lesson 2. so let me copy this
command when you modify it so it's
saying that which where is our API what
else about web hook listening on so
listening on Google host part 3000 slash
API webhook so this corresponded to our
webbook here so now I'm going to press
enter and basically it's gonna set up a
local testing environment for our stripe
so you can see this uh it has given us
our web hook signing secret so I want to
copy this wh SEC all the way to the end
copy it come out to our EnV right and
then just paste it here so next uh sorry
it should be
a stripe
web
hook signing Secret
paste it in here so make sure this
variable is here and then we'll come
down to our uh web hook so we can see
that we have this stripe web hook secret
right here right so make sure that uh
whatever variable here corresponds to
whatever you have within the dot EnV
so then once you have that let us save
the file and then we can actually test
out the uh we can actually test out the
web hook signing
so I'm going to come up I'm going to
open the terminal bigger I'm going to
start my Dev server running again
so
what this is going to do is once we
completed a checkout on the stripe page
it's going to send a web hook to our API
it's going to send a web hook to our
endpoint then we're going to create a
row in the database and then based on
that we can then uh check whether a user
is subscribed to us
so come back here and go refresh the
page wait for next years to compile for
me
okay so as is compiling
okay so uh
everything is up and running again so
I'm going to press upgrade to Pro
it will then lead me to the stripe
checkout page
okay so then I'm going to enter a test
uh test credit card so because we are
testing I can enter something like
uh four two four two four two all the
way
the same here I'll just give it my name
and just press subscribe and I want you
to look carefully as what happens to the
backend so if everything goes well we
should see 200 requests oh for one okay
so my mistake uh I made a mistake here
this will be API says web hook right
it's not apss middleware so that's my
mistake so let's save this and let's try
again so this for one error is is uh
unauthorized right
so let's try again so I'm gonna go to my
uh the go to chest is not finished
implemented so let's just manually go to
our search Chat slash one right
then what I'm gonna do is come down to
our subscription okay so let's try again
so I'm gonna press upgrade to Pro then
it's gonna send me the stripe checkout
page and I'll try again right so four
two four two four two all the way
my name subscribe so buy right if
everything goes well now we can see we
should be able to see 200 requests
coming in up 404 still 404 okay this yet
another a very very silly mistake right
so we can see that uh
let's actually let me see if my EnV file
here so the same mistake that I've made
here is that you can see that uh this
web hook right it has been placed in The
Roots app folder what else this uh
webhook uh folder should actually be
placed within the API folder so I'm
gonna move it up here move it up into
the slash API folder
I'll move it up this will be placed in
the API folder not in the app folder so
I hope you didn't make the same mistake
as me here
so I'm gonna put it in okay so uh
because it's file based routing right so
this webhook has to be placed within the
slash API folder
so let me try one last time so hopefully
this time everything will work so let's
go to
okay so let me just upgrade to Pro
all right so let me test one last time
hopefully this time it will work so four
two four two four two four two four two
four two
subscribe so if you look at the back end
this time it should return us with 200
response and let's see if it works let's
wait for a while
okay yeah it works so now you test with
200 that means everything is worked
everything works perfectly and now if we
could look into our database we should
be able to see the
um we should both see the row
so right now let's create a utility
function to check whether a user is
subscribed to the pro account so come
under to your uh Commander to your let's
see
uh your lip folder and let's create a
file called
subscription.ts okay
so for this subscription.ts uh it will
we have to check whether the row exists
within the database
so what I'm gonna do is first export a
function called check sub
scription it's gonna be in async
function
okay
so we're going to first check if they're
logged in awaits off
so this from uh Clerk
right place from the clock itself uh
let's import it solely
then we'll go attack uh get the user ID
of it we're gonna check if not user ID
we got return to false so if they're not
log in obviously they're not a pro user
then we'll get all the current we'll get
the user subscriptions
so user subscriptions from awaitdb dot
select so this DB comes from our lib
slash DB as usual
dot select Dot from user subscriptions
so this one will come from our schema
where equals to
the user of course I'm blocking it
user
subscriptions dot user
ID equals to user ID
so let's save this so this just merely
checks for whether the row exists
so if not user
subscriptions index 0
right then we know obviously it's false
that means they are not they do not have
a record database so they're not
subscribed
okay so let's get the actual user
subscription from uh underscore user
subscriptions index zero
okay uh and then we're gonna do cons is
valid
is going to be user subscription
dot stripe price ID so they must have a
price ID that exists
as well as the user subscription dot
stripe current period n
don't get time
right
plus uh Plus
let's define one one variable up here
called cons day in milliseconds so how
many milliseconds are in the day 1000
times 60 times 60 times 24 so if the
current period End plus one day in in
milliseconds so we give them a one day
buffer if it is bigger than date dot now
that means it is uh still valid right so
if it's valid if both of these uh
statements are valid right so if the
strike price ID exist and they still
have they are not the expiration is not
over then we want to return not not is
valid so this converts it into a Boolean
okay so this function is exists now for
us to actually check whether the user is
subscribed to a chat PDF Pro so the last
step here is to actually let's come back
down to our
app.tsx so the main page here so above
here
remember here we asked to put the this
go to chats here so uh underneath here
uh underneath here let's add the
subscription button okay so let's
actually get the whether there are pro
account first so we can check each Pro
is pro it goes to a weight check
subscriptions
okay so this subscription obviously is
imported from our a our check
subscription a file then we can create a
new uh component called
sub script option button dot TSX
okay so this subscription button is
going to take in a few things so we do
TS arrayfce first
so it's going to be a client component
all right so this will take in this is
Pro
it's gonna be a Boolean right we're
gonna check uh we're gonna have a
loading state for this
right so we're gonna return a button
right import it just disable when it's
loading
that's gonna say that if if props dot is
pro right we're gonna show manage
subscriptions
get Pro account
okay so then cons handle subscription so
we can copy this code uh Contender
subscription from the uh chat sidebar
right we can see that we have this
handle subscription so let me copy this
and let me paste in here so it's the
same code here so then we just whenever
they click on this button
we want to handle subscribe handle
subscription
right Handle Sub script
all right that's pretty much it so let
me save this so let's import access also
save it then we can come back to our
page.tsx right we can then uh
just import it so underneath this go to
chats button
uh and then just go to chats let us put
the subscription button so we have a
give this is marginal F of 3
and we have the subscript
subscription button
from all components
L pass in the is pro prop is pro
passenger is Pro
so this comes from a tech subscription
function call
okay so uh if everything goes well
right we can now see that there should
be a subscription button that shows up
here so that let's wait for it so in the
meantime let's talk about how do we
implement this go to chats feature so we
need to first we need to get the first
chat within uh that database right so
we're gonna get the ID of the first ever
chat and then we'll link it there link
it down there
so how do you get the first chat right
we're gonna check uh let's first chat
we're gonna check if user ID exists
first then we'll do first uh chat equals
to awaitdb
dot select
Dot from chats throw this from users
schema dot where
the equals where
chats.user ID equals to user ID
okay
then if first check exists they want to
set first
chat to be first chat index 0. so this
variable here returns us with the array
with a list but we want to get the first
element here so the first chat they have
for this user
then we're gonna check here if if it's
off and the first hat exists
okay then we're gonna show this button
that goes to chats however this button
will wrap it in a href tag a link tag so
let me just do here click here so let me
just import the link component
uh link component
I'll wrap the button in here
okay so wrapping this button here this
link will obviously go to
uh sorry
first chat dot ID
so it leads us to the first chat ID so
let's save this file and then let's come
back to our thing so right now I see
this go to chats so let me just add one
more thing let me add one icon to make
it look nicer
so for the icon I'm going to choose the
arrow right icon
so let's get the error icon moving
oh it's really lagging really badly
right now
so uh Arrow right
so import the arrow right icon from
Lucid react let's give you a styling of
um
uh margin left of two so let's save it
uh let me just remove this
okay save it and hopefully that should
be an arrow that pops up and then we'll
be able to style it properly right now
if you go to go to chats it will lead us
to the chat page right so let me go back
here and right now because we are pro
you ask us to manage subscription right
so right now if you press this there is
going to be an error right let's look at
the error and I'm going to explain how
to fix the error so the error is that uh
we need to enable the billing test test
website so let's look at look at the
console for the error
so okay so this error so scroll up to
the error they should if they should
tell you that uh you can create a portal
session in the test mode until you save
your customer portal session so just
click on the link here that goes to test
settings uh billing slash portal open it
in your uh in your browser so it open on
my other browser here I'm gonna bring it
up here
uh
okay and then all you need to do is just
uh enable the building portal
by clicking the button activate test
link okay so that's all that you need to
do then close it off
all right then just come back to your
thing here and if you click on manage
subscription this time it should work
properly
portal where I can manage my
subscriptions okay so that's also
working perfectly so everything is
working fine so here is where they can
manage their subscription like canceling
and yeah
so let me just return to chat PDF so the
go to chat function will also work so I
think that's pretty much it so the last
part here is just to for this upgrade to
Pro account in our chat sidebar
so let me close this off come back to my
chat sidebar okay
so for the chest I bought I'm gonna do
the same for my uh for this button here
uh
upgrade to Pro uh yeah that's pretty
much it that's pretty much it so for
this button I can actually replace it
with my uh
subscription button imported from my
component
so we pass is pro so how do we get the
ispro
uh
we can get its Pro prop from the crop
here
so let's just do
uh is pro this will be a Boolean
then let us destructure it
is Pro
okay
uh
then let's come down here I'll pass this
Pro into this component
so for this subscription button this is
pro we need to go back to our page.tsx
in our chats ID right this is where we
are rendering this chat sidebar
component right
so now we require a is pro prop here
is pro so let's get back to it's Pro by
doing cons uh is pro equals to await
check subscription
okay so let's import this from our
subscription.ts a lib file
so let's wait for it to load
check subscription and invoke it then we
can pasta is
into the chat sidebar
so then we save it and then that's it
for the progress
okay so I think that works perfectly
everything is done so that's it so all
right so we're complete down with the
project and so now I'm going to show the
Deploy on the cell all right so come
down to your come let's go make a new
gate repository from this repo so come
down to your terminal so I'm gonna stop
everything that's running first I'm
gonna stop the server I'll stop this
also exit so I'm gonna do uh let me just
delete this let's do git status so you
can see that we are gonna try to commit
all these files here so let's do git add
dot gets comment Dash am initial comment
all right come down to your browser go
to
github.com new so let's let's create a
new repository together
so here you just name it whatever you
want I'm gonna name it uh chats PDF Dash
YouTube
okay uh just put it as public and create
the repository so usually you follow the
steps that GitHub ask us to do so we
already added and committed right rename
your branch and I'm gonna copy the
remote origin so let's add the origin
and finally let us push it up to Main
so keep push that Shield origin mean so
that will push up all our code to the
GitHub repo so now if we refresh this
page we can see all our uh this we can
see that all our code is being pushed up
so now all we need to do is come down to
uh versal versal.com
add a new project so add new project and
what you can do is import your chat well
chat PDF that's YouTube for the project
name and for this environmental
variables come back to your dot EnV file
okay so I'm going to copy up everything
except for this next base URL right here
so click copy from all the way here all
the way up
okay copy this okay then paste it into
my in variables so the last thing here
is I need to add a
sorry I need to add this what's it
called Next base URL so let's copy this
so let me add the next base URL and this
will be later on will be changed on this
will be later change to whatever the
cell gives you all right so let me just
delete this so that we can deploy first
so for now we do have to add that URL
but later when we deploy once we get the
Versa URL we can just place it back
there so I think that might be an error
but let's see as it builds
okay so the project has been deployed
successfully all right so let us go to
the continue to dashboard and let's
actually try out ourselves so I'm gonna
visit this domain check PDF that's
youtube.result.app so this is the URL
that we need to place into our uh next
base URL later on so for now let's
actually log in to get started so I'm
going to click on it login it will bring
us to the the clerk page so I'm gonna
log into my with my Google account and
just log in with my here and so it will
lead me back to my to the home page
where hopefully I'll be logged in
okay so that's good so right now I can
see that my chats are great so let me go
to the chat page so you can see the
chats being shown here so let me create
a new chat by dropping a new PDF here so
let me drop back in the
um
Edge runtime docs to make sure
everything's working so hopefully that
this will work so I'm gonna show you how
to actually add one more configuration
to your cell app later but let's see if
this works alright so it works check
created and we can see that the runtime
works the PDF is here and let's ask a
question
um let's ask how to use the edge runtime
question mark So this should give me a a
response in regards to the PDF okay so
correct these are all pulling directly
from the Versa docs you can see that it
says result in it so we know that things
works and everything is perfect
so the last thing here is let us change
the environmental variables for stripe
and for the base URL
so come back to your uh virtual
dashboard okay come down to your
settings come down to your functions
right choose a function that is nearest
to you so choose for me in this case
will be Singapore okay save it so this
is where all my serverless functions
will execute so obviously you have to
choose one that's nearest to you and
your users so that the response time
will be fast
okay so with that of the way let us come
back to our general come back to our
environmental variables right so we need
uh the so remember that we have this
next base URL so let's fill that in
right now so let us add a URL code next
base URL so this we can just copy from
the base url url here so copy here and
let us pasting the value here okay so
I'm gonna save this file okay and also
for the Forester stripe web hook signing
secret come back to our dashboard here
okay
come back to web hooks all right we want
to now add an endpoint so this endpoint
will be at our Versa URL slash API says
web hook right and we want to select
events to listen on so what events are
we listening on to our webhook so
remember we are listening for checkout
section completed and invoice payment
succeeded so let's add these two
endpoints so firstly uh check out the
sessions Dot
dot completed
right and also we have a invoice.payment
succeeded invoice dot payment
dot succeeded sorry invoice dot payment
underscore
succeeded okay so it's just these two
these two uh events that we're listening
on then we'll add the events
and then uh that's pretty much it then
you can just add the endpoint and
everything will work perfectly so now we
will get this signing secret which we
have to this is the actual official one
so copy this coming to you know even in
variables come into our
uh
stripe workbook training secret and let
us edit this
so just replace it with the one that you
pasted in copied press it save right and
one more thing I want to change here is
now the button looks kind of ugly within
the chat here see this many subscription
so I'm gonna just change that by going
into our subscription button so I'm
going to change this um button to a type
variance off sorry
variance of outline so I'm going to save
it and I'll push the code up to my
repository so I'm gonna just put change
button commit and push so whenever I
push uh versus automatically going to
detect there's new changes it's going to
redeploy the entire application for me
so we come back to our original Versa
application right come back to our
deployments and we're able to see it has
detected that we have a new commit code
change button so if we come into our
click onto in here we're able to see the
deployment status the commit change
right and let us click into it so that
we can see what's happening
okay so now we just have to wait for it
to deploy and then everything should be
up and running and ready to go
okay so now that I have finally deployed
let's visit the original page so let me
just go back to our original uh home
page and everything should work fine yes
so now we have we change the button so
we go to chat at least the button
doesn't look uh that ugly anymore so I
mean you can start it further but in
this case I'll just leave it up to you
so yeah we have completed this whole
project I'm very happy and very proud of
you for staying all the way to the end
and falling through this project and
yeah you feel free to continue improving
on this project and eventually turning
into a real sales product where you can
be really making money off of this so I
hope you have learned something from
this video so today I thought um I
taught mainly about AI right how to use
a retriever augmented generation to fit
in proper contacts into a chat GPT right
so I hope that this has been helpful to
you and if you have learned something
new today uh please do like comment and
subscribe on this video because I put I
mean I put a lot of effort I hope that
you actually learned something and I
provided a value to you so with that
thank you for watching and have a good
day